[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ओके आई थिंक
वी आर लाइव अ
आई थिंक वी आर लाइव इन राइट वी आर लाइव
राइट आई थिंक यस सो या हेलो एवरीवन गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ यू प्लीज लेट मी नो क्या
मैं ऑडिबल हूं विज़िबल हूं क्लियरली सब कुछ
मैं इनफॉर्म कर देता हूं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल
ऑफ यू। गुड इवनिंग। ओके। ऑडियो बिल्कुल
सही आ रही है?
ऑडियो बिल्कुल सही आ रही है। मुझे एक बार
बता दीजिए।
गुड इवनिंग।
नमस्ते। नमस्ते। नमस्ते। गुड इवनिंग।
ऑडियो में तो कोई इशू नहीं आ रही है। ठीक
है। ठीक है। परफेक्ट। बढ़िया।
सो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़]
ओके। बिफोर वी स्टार्ट।
मैं एक मिनट लूंगा आपका। जस्ट सेकंड।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके अ गुड इवनिंग ठीक है आई एम आई एम गुड
आई एम गुड मृत्यु
मिस्टर जेट टॉप आई एम वेरी गुड थैंक यू
फॉर आस्किंग सो आप सभी कैसे हैं मुझे यह
भी बता दीजिए आप सभी लोग बढ़िया है। काफी
दिनों बाद हम मिल रहे हैं। सो जस्ट लेट मी
नो इफ यू ऑल आर गुड।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके।
एवरीवन इज़ सुपर फाइन। ठीक है।
चलिए बढ़िया। सो आई होप आप सब ने जो बीच का
गैप मिला आप लोग को काफी अच्छा गैप मिला
है क्लास एट के बाद। ठीक है? क्लास नाइन
के पहले आप लोगों को एक अच्छा टाइमलाइन
मिला। एक अच्छा गैप मिला। एंड मैं ऐसा
उम्मीद करता हूं कि आपने इस गैप को जो है
पॉजिटिवली यूज करके एंड जितने भी पहले की
कांसेप्ट्स थे, स्किल्स थे जो आपने सीखे
थे और जो एडिशनल टॉपिक्स मैं डील करता हूं
उसको भी आपने कवर किया होगा एंड आपने
रिवाइज करा होगा एंड आपको चीजें जो हैं वो
अच्छे से और भी ज्यादा क्लियर हुई होंगी।
उनके थ्रू। मैं ऐसा उम्मीद करता हूं। आई
डोंट नो कि आप में से कितने लोग यह अ काम
कितने लोगों ने करा है? आई रियली डोंट नो
बट आई होप कि आप में से मैक्सिमम लोगों ने
करा हो। एंड आई विश द सेम। सो मुझे एक बार
बता दीजिए कि आप लोगों में से कितने लोगों
ने इस पर्टिकुलर गैप में सेशन एट तक क्लास
एट तक की वीडियोस को अगेन रिवाइज करा और
उन वीडियोस के अंदर जो टॉपिक्स मैं डील
करता हूं। जैसे मान लो मैंने पासवर्ड
क्रैकिंग के टॉपिक्स डील करे और पासवर्ड
क्रैकिंग के अलग-अलग टेक्निक्स के बारे
में बताया। तो उस टेक्निक को भी एक्सप्लोर
करा एंड उस टेक्निक के बारे में भी पढ़ा
है, नॉलेज ली है। तो कितने लोग आप में से
हैं ऐसे? ऐसे महारथी कितने लोग हैं? मुझे
बस बता दीजिए एक बार। एंड
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सभी को एक
बार आ जाने देते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके
ओके काफी लोग काफी लोग बोल तो रहे हैं
यहां पे कि अ मैंने करा है या उन्होंने
करा है। बट आई डोंट नो एग्जैक्टली कि आप
में से सच कितने लोग बोल रहे हैं। क्योंकि
बोलने के लिए तो आप कुछ भी बोल सकते हैं।
बट स्टिल आई एम अस्यूमिंग कि आप में से
मैक्सिमम लोगों ने ये चीज करी है। एंड मैं
ऐसा
मैं ट्रस्ट कर सकता हूं। इससे ज्यादा तो
मैं कुछ नहीं कर सकता। आई डोंट नो आप में
से कितने लोगों ने करा है। बट अगर आपने
करा है तो यह आपके लिए ही करा है।
यू हैव [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] डन फॉर
योरसेल्फ नॉट फॉर मसेल्फ। राइट? चलिए तो
आज से सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं और एक
आपसे रिक्वेस्ट है सभी लोगों से कि जैसा
कि मैंने पहले ही बोल रखा है कि सेशन हर
सेशन के वीडियोस पे अप्रोक्स पहले मैं 250
कमेंट्स की आपको मैंने एक टारगेट दिया था।
अब मैं उसको 200 कमेंट्स कर रहा हूं।
क्योंकि 250 तो आप करते-करते पता नहीं
कितना टाइम लगा दे रहे हो। सो आई एम जस्ट
अह
कम सेइंग रिड्यूसिंग इट टू 200। ठीक है?
तो अ देखो अ
सर क्लास की फ्रीक्वेंसी बहुत लेट हो रहा
है। एक वीक में दो क्लास प्लीज। हां
बिल्कुल सही बात है। फ्रीक्वेंसी इज़ लेट।
आई नो बट वो मेरे हाथ में नहीं है। मैंने
पहले ही बोल रखा है आपको। सभी को बोल रखा
है। अब जो है नेक्स्ट क्लासेस है इस
क्लासेस को भी इंक्लूड करके। जितने भी
वीडियोस होंगे उस पे आप एटलीस्ट 200 प्लस
कमेंट्स करेंगे। पहले 250 था तो नेक्स्ट
वीडियो आपके सामने हाजिर हो जाएगी। बट याद
रखिएगा एक बंदा 10 कमेंट कर देगा ऐसे तो
वो वैलिड नहीं होता है। मैं उसको एक ही
कमेंट काउंट करूंगा। चाहे इवन आप डिफरेंट
मल्टीपल आईडी से भी बुक कर रहे हो या जो
भी है व्हाटएवर। सो आप प्लीज यूनिक
कमेंट्स कीजिएगा। ये मैं जानबूझकर बोलता
हूं ताकि आप लोग इंटरेक्ट जबरदस्ती भी
करें कम से कम। एंड आप लोगों को चिंता हो
नई क्लासेस का, नेक्स्ट क्लासेस का। तो
मैं अभी कोशिश कर रहा हूं कि मैं
फ्रीक्वेंटली क्लासेस और ज्यादा
फ्रीक्वेंट लेकर आऊं। मैं पूरी आपके लिए
अवेलेबल रहूंगा। बट आपको भी मेरे लिए
अवेलेबल रहना पड़ेगा। अगर आप अवेलेबल नहीं
रहेंगे तो आई डोंट थिंक कि मैं आपके लिए
अवेलेबल रह पाऊंगा। उस तरीके से जितनी
सिंसियरनेस के साथ मैं ये जो क्लासेस है
वो करा रहा हूं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके चलिए
ओके नाउ बिफोर वी स्टार्ट यहां पे मैं आप
सब से जानना चाहता हूं क्या आप सबकी
रिवीजन हो चुकी है ऑलरेडी क्या सबकी
रिवीजन रिवीजन हो चुकी है ऑलरेडी अभी तक
की
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
रिवीजन [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सबकी हो
चुकी है। लास्ट क्लास रिमेनिंग है। ठीक
है? आई होप कि आप लास्ट क्लास की भी
रिवीजन कर लेंगे। जल्दी कर लेंगे। मैं ऐसा
उम्मीद करता हूं एंड उसको भी कंप्लीट कर
लेंगे। चलिए आज की सेशन हम स्टार्ट करते
हैं। यहां पे बिफोर वी स्टार्ट मैं आपको
पहले ही बोल चुका हूं कि
सबसे पहला काम है 200 प्लस कमेंट वीडियो
के ऊपर नेक्स्ट क्लास के लिए। दूसरा काम
है किसी भी वीडियो में लाइव सेक्शन में
जाइएगा। किसी भी एसओसी के जो वीडियोस हैं
आप उसको ओपन कर लीजिएगा। इन वीडियोस के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में जब आप आएंगे तो दो लिंक
मिलेंगे। एक WhatsApp ग्रुप का और एक
WhatsApp चैनल का। WhatsApp ग्रुप एसओसी
का स्पेशल एसओसी ओनली ग्रुप है। जहां पर
आपको सारे रिसोर्सेज एसओसी के नोट्स और जो
भी अपडेट्स हैं ना एसओसी के इस ट्रेनिंग
के बारे में वो सबसे पहले मिल जाती है।
एंड यहीं पे मिलेगी आपको। और जो हमारा
WhatsApp चैनल है यह आप यहां पे आके
11,000 डिफ्रॉनिक्सर्स के साथ जुड़ सकते
हैं। एंड हमारे कंपनी हमारी कोर्सेज
ट्रेनिंग्स एंड जो भी डिटेल्स सबसे पहले
अपडेट्स आपको WhatsApp चैनल पे मिलता है।
तो ये दोनों चीजें आप जॉइ कर लीजिएगा,
फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। रही बात Lindin की तो
यहां पे मेरा Lindin का प्रोफाइल है। आप
Lindin पे आके मुझे फॉलो करके मुझसे
कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं यहां पे एंड जुड़ सकते
हैं मेरे साथ। एंड Lindin पे आप dfonic जब
सर्च करेंगे सिंपल डिफ्रॉनिक्स सर्च
करेंगे तो आप डिफ़्रॉनिक्स के Lindin पेज
पे हमारे आ जाएंगे। जहां पर आप हमारी
कंपनी के Lindin पेज के साथ जुड़ सकते हैं।
जहां पे ऑलमोस्ट 21,000 प्लस डिफॉनिस्टर्स
हमसे जुड़े हुए हैं। हमारे कंपनी का, हमारे
स्टार्टअप का, हमारे आने वाली चीजों के
प्रोडक्ट के बारे में एंड जो भी अपडेट्स
हैं, आप इसको ट्रैक डाउन कर सकते हैं।
लाइक हाउ वी आर ऑपरेटिंग, व्हाट वी आर
डूइंग, व्हाट वी आर अप टू एवरीथिंग। ठीक
है? [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] देन यह
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] हमारा एक्स
पेज है डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी हैंडल के साथ।
यहां पे आके आप Twitter या एक्स पे हमें
फॉलो कर सकते हैं। यहां पे भी फ़दर आपको
बहुत सारी अनाउंसमेंट्स आने वाली है। वह
आपको यहां पे मिल जाएंगी। तो यह सारी
चीजें जो है आपको एक्सप्लोर कर लेनी है।
एंड साथ ही हमारी ये वेबसाइट है
dfonic.com आप इस पे आके यहां आपको हमारा
एक नंबर मिलेगा। आप इस पे हमसे किसी भी
तरह की क्वेरीज WhatsApp के ऊपर पूछ सकते
हैं। एंड ये हमारी वेबसाइट को एक्सप्लोर
कर सकते हैं। एकडमी पे जाके हमारे
रिकॉर्डेड प्री रिकॉर्डेड वीडियो कोर्सेज
को एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। एंड इनको एनरोल
कर सकते हैं। चलिए।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सो नाउ लेट्स कम टू द
टॉपिक टुडेेस टॉपिक। आज की जो टॉपिक है वो
काफी एक इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक होने वाली है
एंड काफी ज्यादा हेल्पफुल है आपके एसओसी
जर्नी के लिए क्योंकि उसके बिना आप एसओसी
एलोन नहीं बन सकते। मैंने लास्ट ही सेशन
में आपको पासवर्ड क्रैकिंग ये सब
टेक्निक्स जो है वो बताई मैंने अगर मैं
आपको लास्ट सेशन की पीपीटी आपको दिखाऊं तो
मैंने आपको लास्ट सेशन में यहां पे
पासवर्ड अटैक्स के बारे में बताया था।
उसके टाइप्स वगैरह में सारे टाइप्स को
एक्सप्लेन आपको करे हुए थे। जितने भी
पासवर्ड अटैक्स के टाइप्स हैं वो सारी
एसओसी का इन्वेस्टिगेशन वर्क फ्लो बताया
था आपको। प्रिवेंशन मैकेनिज्म ये वगैरह
बताया था। अटैक्स के कंपैरिजन वगैरह बताए
थे। ये सारी चीजें आपको बताई गई थी। अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] जब हम
पासवर्ड अटैक के बारे में पढ़ते हैं तो
हमारा सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट पॉइंट सबसेेंट चीज
एक और होता है पढ़ना एंड दैट इज कॉल्ड
हैशिंग एंड सॉल्टिंग हैशिंग एंड सॉल्टिंग
इसके बारे में भी पढ़ना उतना ही
इंपॉर्टेंट है जितना पासवर्ड
अटैक या ब्रड फ़ोर्स या व्हाटएवर पासवर्ड
अटैक टाइप्स या जो भी चीज़ हैं आप जितना
उतना जितना उस वो इंपॉर्टेंट है उतना ही
आपके लिए ये इंपॉर्टेंट है क्योंकि उसका
एक नेक्स्ट कांसेप्ट है यह जो मैं आपको आज
कराने वाला हूं। ठीक है? चलिए अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके। सबसे पहला कांसेप्ट है हमारा हैशिंग
का। जब आप पासवर्ड क्रैकिंग कर रहे होते
हैं तो मैं यह जो भी चीजें या जो भी ये आप
टॉपिक्स पढ़ रहे हैं यह जो टॉपिक्स आप देख
रहे हैं ये सब एसओसी एल वन रोल के लिए ही
है। याद रखिएगा आप ये चीज एसओसी लेवल वन
रोल के लिए जो टॉपिक्स की रिक्वायरमेंट है
जो चीजें आपको चाहिए जो आपको जानना चाहिए
वो सारी चीजें ही हैं ये। तो इसमें ऐसा ये
ऐसा नहीं है कि अ ये जो चीजें मैं आपको
बता रहा हूं ये अनरिलेटेड होगा या कुछ भी।
अब मैं ये चीजें इतना डिटेल में इसलिए बता
रहा हूं नेक्स्ट पार्ट हां बिल्कुल सही
बात है। सही बात है। सर वीडियो की
फ्रीक्वेंसी बढ़ा बढ़ाओ प्लीज दो इन
वीक्स। मैं वीडियो की फ्रीक्वेंसी मैं
आपको पहले ही बता रहा हूं। देखो मैं पहले
बोल चुका हूं। फिर बोल दे रहा हूं। वीडियो
की फ्रीक्वेंसी मेरे ऊपर डिपेंड नहीं करती
है। वीडियो की फ्रीक्वेंसी आपके ऊपर
डिपेंड करती है। आप 200 प्लस कमेंट्स कर
दो हर वीडियो पे तो आपको वीक में एक या दो
नहीं तीन-तीन क्लासेस मैं लाके दे दूंगा।
थ्री क्लासेस आई कैन ब्रिंग इन अ वीक। तो
आप प्लीज वो 200 प्लस कमेंट्स वाला टारगेट
पूरा कीजिए। इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट। दैट्स इट।
ठीक है?
ओके।
सर व्हेन प्रैक्टिकल? प्रैक्टिकल के लिए
अभी आप दूसरा रिसोर्स देखिए। प्रैक्टिकल
के लिए यह चैनल पे आप आने की अगर आप सोच
रहे हैं कि सिर्फ मैं प्रैक्टिकल बता के
और आपको कुछ भी समझा दूंगा तो यह चैनल फिर
आपके लिए और यह ट्रेनिंग आपके लिए नहीं है
क्योंकि ये ट्रेनिंग जॉब ओरिएंटेड
ट्रेनिंग है एसोस एल वन के लिए सिर्फ
प्रैक्टिकल ट्रेनिंग नहीं है कि ये
प्रैक्टिकल करा दो जब जॉब ओरिएंटेड
ट्रेनिंग की बात करते हैं तो इसका मतलब है
आपको ज़ीरो से हीरो बनाना ज़ीरो से हीरो
फ्रॉम ए टू जेड सिखाना उसमें थ्योरी भी
आती है प्रैक्टिकल भी आती है
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन लैब्स सैमुलेशन सब आता है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] तो हम सब कुछ
समझेंगे, पढ़ेंगे। ठीक है? अब मैं आपको
प्रैक्टिकल में फिशिंग का एसआईएम
प्रैक्टिकल दिखा दूं। मान लो किसी भी मान
लो स्प्लंक वगैरह का यूज़ करके जो भी है।
आपको पता ही नहीं होगा स्प्लंक में फिर
कैसे एनालिसिस करेंगे, कैसे क्या करेंगे?
आप कैसे जानोगे जब तक आप थ्योरी नहीं
जानोगे। राइट? दैट्स द थिंग। सो सुमित जी
प्लीज आप अगर प्लीज आप रिपीटेड मत कीजिए।
अ इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़] सो यहां पे द फर्स्ट
थिंग इज़ व्हाट इज़ हैशिंग? तो हम जब
पासवर्ड क्रैकिंग करते हैं, पासवर्ड
अटैक्स करते हैं, तो उसमें एक सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट टर्म होता हैशिंग का। अब देखो
पासवर्ड्स जो स्टर्ड होते हैं ना सर्वर
सर्वर पे जो डेटाबेस में पासवर्ड स्टोर
होते हैं वो सिंपल प्लेन टेक्स्ट में तो
स्टर्ड होते नहीं है। क्योंकि अगर सिंपल
प्लेन टेक्स्ट में पासवर्ड स्टोर होने लगे
और अगर डेटाबेस हैक हो जाती है किसी
वेबसाइट की तो प्लेन टेक्स्ट का पासवर्ड
अटैकर को आराम से मिल जाएगा। कोई ज्यादा
अह उसको एफर्ट नहीं लगाना पड़ेगा एंड
प्लेन टेक्स्ट पासवर्ड मिल जाएगी। राइट?
तो दिस इज़ और दिस कैन बी वेरी डेंजरस। सो
पासवर्ड्स जो होते हैं उनको स्टोर किया
जाता है एक डिफरेंट फॉर्मेट में जिसको हम
हैश बोलते हैं। हैश एच ए एस एच। और इस
प्रोसेस को उस पासवर्ड को हैश में कन्वर्ट
करने के प्रोसेस को हम हैशिंग बोलते हैं।
सो यहां पे पहले हम हैशिंग को समझते हैं।
अ हैश इज अ वन वे मैथमेटिकल
ट्रांसफॉर्मेशन ऑफ डेटा इंटू अ फिक्स्ड
लेंथ स्ट्रिंग। हैशिंग का मतलब होता है ये
एक मैथमेटिकल
अ तरीका है। ट्रांसफॉर्मेशन है। क्या करने
का? डेटा को एक फिक्स्ड लेंथ स्ट्रिंग में
कन्वर्ट करने का। देखो हैशिंग और
इंक्रिप्शन में बहुत डिफरेंस है। बहुत
ज्यादा डिफरेंस है। हैशिंग जो होती है
इसमें आप किसी भी डेटा को एक फिक्स्ड लेंथ
स्ट्रिंग में कन्वर्ट करते हो। बट
इंक्रिप्शन में क्या होता है? एक प्लेन
टेक्स्ट डेटा को आप साइफर टेक्स्ट में या
इंक्रिप्टेड टेक्स्ट में कन्वर्ट करते हो।
दोनों में बहुत अंतर है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हम इंक्रिप्शन
के बारे में भी जानेंगे बट पहले हम हैशिंग
को समझेंगे। तो हैश क्या होता है? वन वे
मैथमेटिकल ट्रांसफॉर्मेशन बट इंक्रिप्शन
टू वे अप्रोच होता है। टू वे मैकेनिज्म
होता है। अब वही वन वे क्या है? टू वे
क्या है? वो भी मैं आपको समझाऊंगा। ठीक
है? [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सर एप्रिशिएट योर हार्ड वर्क। सर ये सीरीज
कंप्लीट करने के बाद और फिर कहीं जॉब का
अप्लाई करें तो क्या कॉम्पटी सिक्योरिटी
प्लस या का सर्टिफिकेट के बिना जॉब मिल
जाएगा? बिल्कुल आप बिल्कुल अ कहीं पे
अप्लाई कर सकते हैं। इस ट्रेनिंग के बाद
आप कहीं पे भी अप्लाई कर सकते हैं फॉर
एसोसियल वन। एनीवेयर कहीं पे भी यहां पे
वैकेंसीज है एसओसीएल वन के लिए इस
ट्रेनिंग के बाद आप कर सकते हैं अप्लाई।
दैट्स इट। ठीक है?
ओके गौरव। एआई रिप्लेस। अरे भाई यहां तो
देख लो भाई। कोई जॉब रिप्लेस नहीं कर रहा।
एसओसी की जॉब के लिए भी आप एसओसी की
लर्निंग लेके और एआई की भी नॉलेज आपको
रखोगे। आपको कोई रिप्लेस नहीं करेगा। एआई
की नॉलेज रखनी जरूरी है। तो एक टर्म जो
काफी ज्यादा पॉपुलर हुआ था कि एआई विल नॉट
रिप्लेस यू बट अ पर्सन विथ द एi नॉलेज कैन
रिप्लेस यू। तो आपको भी अ पर्सन विद ए
नॉलेज बनना है। सिंपल। हर डोमेन में एआई
को ऐड कर दो। एआई की थोड़ी नॉलेज ले लो।
दैट्स इट खत्म। ठीक है?
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है। ओके। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
चलिए।
[खांसने की आवाज़]
तो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
जो पासवर्ड हम क्रैक करने के लिए पासवर्ड
क्रैकिंग वगैरह जो करते हैं या अटैकर्स
करते हैं पासवर्ड अटैक्स करते हैं उस
पासवर्ड को डेटाबेस में हैज़्ड फॉर्मेट में
स्टोर करके रखा जाता है ना कि प्लेन
टेक्स्ट फॉर्मेट में ना कि प्लेन फॉर्मेट
में। तो होता क्या है? इनपुट
जो पासवर्ड की होती है#श फंक्शन अप्लाई
होता है उस पे#श एल्गोरिदम बोल सकते हो
एंड फिक्स्ड लेंथ आउटपुट जो है वो निकल के
आ जाती है यही होता है जब भी आप पासवर्ड
डालते हो तो उस पे एक हैश एल्गोरिदम चलती
है हैशिंग एल्गोरिदम जिसको बोलते हैं और
फिर एक फिक्स्ड लेंथ का आउटपुट निकल के
सामने आ जाता है अगर मान लो पासवर्ड क्या
है पासवर्ड 1 2 3 है तो अगर मैं एक हैशिंग
मैकेनिज्म जिसका नाम MD5 होता है उसको यूज़
कर रहा हूं तो
कुछ इस तरीके की एक फिक्स्ड लेंथ स्ट्रिंग
आपके सामने [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हैश होने के बाद आ जाएगी। नो मैटर हाउ
लॉन्ग इनपुट इज आउटपुट लेंथ इज फिक्स्ड।
तो इनपुट कितना भी बड़ा हो डजंट मैटर
आउटपुट का जो लेंथ है हैशिंग में वो
फिक्स्ड होता है। दैट्स इट। सो एक सिंपल
सा एक पासवर्ड होता है प्लेन टेक्स्ट का।
इस पे एक हैश फंक्शन मान लो अप्लाई कर
दिया गया। ठीक है? एंड जिसका नाम है मान
लो बी क्रिप्ट अप्लाई कर दिया गया एंड
उसके बाद यहां पे हैशड पासवर्ड जो है वो
निकल कर आ जाती है। बस यही होता है अभी
आपको हैशिंग का बेसिक मैंने आपको समझाया
है। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आपको बेसिक
समझाया है। अब आते हैं प्रॉपर्टीज ऑफ
हैकिंग। प्रॉपर्टीज ऑफ़ हैशिंग सॉरी
हैशिंग। हैशिंग के प्रॉपर्टीज क्या है? तो
ये एक वन वे फंक्शन होता है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] वन वे
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] फंक्शन कैन
नॉट रिवर्स ईजीली। इसको ईली आप रिवर्स
नहीं कर सकते। दिस इज अ वन वे फंक्शन।
मतलब आप सिर्फ आउटगोइंग है। ये आउटगोइंग
है। गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग। ये आउटगोइंग
है। इनकमिंग नहीं है। एक ही फंक्शन इस पे
काम करेगा। डिटरमिनिस्टिक सेम इनपुट सेम
आउटपुट। मतलब डिटरमिनिस्टिक का मतलब है कि
अगर आपका पासवर्ड पासवर्ड 1 2 3 है। ठीक
है? तो यह पासवर्ड अगर कोई भी यूजर यूज़ कर
रहा है उसके हैशेस सेम ही मिलेंगे।
पासवर्ड 1 2 3 का पासवर्ड हमेशा सेम होगा।
मतलब उसका हैश हमेशा सेम होगा। अगर आपका
पासवर्ड है डिफ्रॉनिक्स 1 2 3 तो
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स 1 2 3 का हैश ऑलवेज सिमिलर
होगा। इसलिए यहां पे है डिटरमिनिस्टिक सेम
इनपुट सेम आउटपुट। ठीक है? फिक्स्ड आउटपुट
लेंथ। अब इसमें आउटपुट की जो लेंथ होती है
वो एकदम फिक्स्ड होती है। ऑलवेज फिक्स्ड।
सेम स्मॉल इनपुट चेंज कंप्लीटली डिफरेंट
आउटपुट। अब आपने इनपुट में थोड़ा चेंज कर
दिया। जैसे अब मान
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] लो कि
[खांसने की आवाज़] मैं यहां पे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
मैं यहां पर लेट्स सपोज
यस
लेट्स सपोज कि मैंने यहां पर पासवर्ड दिया
डिफ्रॉनिक्स 1 2 3 ठीक है तो अब इसका मान
लो#श इसका हैश मान लो ये आया कुछ भी मैं
एनीथिंग मैं रैंडम टाइप कर दे रहा हूं ये
आया अब अगर मैंने पासवर्ड को डिफ्रॉनिक्स
1 2 3 के जगह पे मैंने यहां पे रख दिया
साइबर 1 2 3 ऐसे कर दिया तो अब इसकी जो
हैश होगी वह बिल्कुल डिफरेंट आएगी। द हैश
विल बी डिफरेंट फॉर दिस पर्टिकुलर इनपुट।
तो सिमिलर थिंग इज़ बीइंग यहां पे मैं
सिमिलर चीजें आपको यहां पे बताने की कोशिश
कर रहा हूं। द स्मॉल इनपुट चेंज करेंगे।
कंप्लीटली डिफरेंट आउटपुट आपको मिलेगा।
दैट्स सिंपल।
अ [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] पासवर्ड वन टू
थ्री एंड पासवर्ड वन टू फोर दोनों में
कंप्लीट डिफरेंट है। डिफरेंट हैज़ आपको
मिलेंगे। एंड इसी को हम एलेंजेचे इफेक्ट
भी बोलते हैं। अब ये इंटरव्यू क्वेश्चंस
हैं आपके कि आपसे पूछ दिया जाएगा कि एल
इफेक्ट क्या होता हैशिंग में? तो आपको
बताना है वहां पे कि सिंपल वहां पे आपको
बताना है कि व्हेन वी प्रोवाइड व्हेन वी
मेक चेंजेस अ स्मॉल चेंजेस इन द इनपुट वी
गेट अ डिफरेंट आउटपुट एंड एंड अ डिफरेंट
हैश। दिस इज़ कॉल्ड एवल इफेक्ट। सिंपल। तो
जब आप चीजों को अच्छे से समझना शुरू
करेंगे ना, अच्छे से क्लियर करना शुरू
करेंगे, समझना शुरू करेंगे तो आपको
क्वेश्चंस भी मिलेंगे उसके और उसके आंसर्स
भी मिलेंगे। और
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यही तो
क्वेश्चंस होते हैं जो इंटरव्यूअर बनाते
हैं। आपको क्या लगता है? बहुत सारे
इंटरव्यूअर ऐसे क्वेश्चंस पूछते हैं जो
आपको इंटरनेट पे जल्दी कहीं नहीं मिलेगा।
मोस्टली होता है ऐसा। कई ऐसे जैसे 10
क्वेश्चन पूछे ना तो उसमें से दो-तीन
क्वेश्चंस आपको इंटरनेट पे कहीं नहीं
मिलेंगे। तो वो कैसे पूछता है? कैसे पूछ
पाता है? वो आप भी पूछ पाओगे किसी को या
आप भी वैसे क्वेश्चंस बना पाओगे अगर आपका
कांसेप्ट बहुत क्लियर है। तो आपके एक-एक
छोटी-छोटी चीजों को आपने नोट करा है। आपको
इसका एग्जांपल देता हूं। आप सबको पता है
एनसीईआरटी की बुक होती है। सब अभी जो
साइंस वंस वाले या किसी भी
डोमेन के होंगे तो एनसीईआरटी के बुक्स
पढ़ते हैं। चाहे वो सोशल साइंस की बुक्स
पढ़ रहे हो, चाहे वो साइंस के बुक्स पढ़
रहे हो, कोई से भी बुक्स। अब एनसीआरटी में
स्पेशली अगर साइंस की बुक्स की मैं बात
करूं यहां पे पीसीएम वालों की, पीसीबी
वालों की तो तो एक चैप्टर को चारप पन्नों
में निपटा दिया। अब वो चार पांच पन्नों
में तो उन्होंने निपटा दिया। बट आपसे
कॉम्पिटिटिव एग्जामिनेशंस में ऐसे
क्वेश्चंस कर लेंगे जो आपका दिमाग खराब कर
सकता है। अब आप सोचोगे अरे वो चार पांच
पन्नों में तो था ही नहीं। बट एक्चुअली
होता है वो। एक्चुअली वो चार पांच पन्नों
में भी वो चीजें होती हैं। बट हम हम एक-एक
लाइन एक-एक चीजें पढ़ने की हमें आदत ही
नहीं है। हम ऊपर ऊपर का अरे हां ये कर
लिया। अरे हां वो कर लिया। इस तरीके से।
सो ये आदत है हमारी। तो जब तक हम घुसेंगे
नहीं
इनसाइड पूरी तरीके से नहीं घुसेंगे तब तक
हमारा कांसेप्ट क्लियर नहीं होगा। सो यहां
पे आपको समझ [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] लो
कि आप हर एक डोमेन के टॉपिक्स एंड
कांसेप्ट्स को एनसीईआरटी की बुक समझो
जिसको कि आपको डीप घुस के पढ़ना है ताकि
कोई भी टाइप का क्वेश्चन आ जाए चाहे असरशन
रीजन आ जाए चाहे आपका नॉर्मल एमसीक्यू आ
जाए चाहे थोड़ा सा ट्विस्टेड एमसी
एमसीक्यू आ जाए आप सबके आंसर इजिली कर
पाओ। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] राइट?
थैंक यू ब्रदर। लव फ्रॉम इंडिया।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
तो, ये होते हैं प्रॉपर्टीज ऑफ़ हैशिंग।
सिंपल। वन वेव होता है। एक सिर्फ एक बार
आप हैश कर सकते हैं। उसको अनहैश नहीं कर
सकते हैं। डिटरमिनिस्टिक होती है। फिक्स्ड
आउटपुट लेंथ होता है और स्मॉल इनपुट चेंज।
स्मॉल छोटा सा चेंज करोगे आउटपुट आपका
चेंज हो जाएगा। ठीक है? ये सिंपल सा चीज़
है। दैट्स इट। अब यहां पे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब यहां पे एक कॉमन हैश एल्गोरिदम्स के
बारे में और उनके बारे में थोड़ी डिटेल
आपको बता देता हूं। देयर आर सेवरल हैशिंग
एल्गोरिदम और हैशिंग फंक्शन यू कैन से इन
द मार्केट। बहुत सारे होते हैं। आप हैशिंग
एल्गोरिदम को एक्सप्लोर भी कर सकते हैं।
ये एज अ टास्क आप रखिए नेक्स्ट क्लास के
पहले कि आपको डिफरेंट टाइप्स ऑफ हैशिंग
एल्गोरिदम और फंक्शन को एक्सप्लोर करना है
कि कौन-कौन से होते हैं और वो किस तरीके
से काम करते हैं। और अगेन आई एम अगेन आई
विल से कि दिस क्लास इज़ नॉट फॉर
क्रिप्टोग्राफी स्पेसिफिक क्लास नॉट फॉर
एथिकल हैकिंग। एसओसी के लिए है। तो एसओसी
के लिए जितनी नॉलेज चाहिए मैं आपको दे रहा
हूं। आप इस नॉलेज को गैब करके अच्छे से
एंड अपने दिमाग में बिठा के रखिए। बाकी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एक्स्ट्रा चीजें
आपको एक्सप्लोर करनी चाहिए। ये मैं हमेशा
से बोलता हूं। फिर मैं बोलूंगा। तो आपका
ये टास्क है। हैश एल्गोरिदम्स जितने भी
होते हैं उसकी लिस्ट आपको फाइंड करनी है।
उसके बारे में पता करना है। और एक-एक
हैशिंग एल्गोरिदम कैसे काम करती है उसका
मोटा-मोटा ओवरव्यू लेना है। बहुत डीप नहीं
जाना है क्योंकि बहुत डीप जाओगे तो जाते
रह जाओगे। खत्म नहीं होंगी इसके बारे में
डिटेल। ठीक है? [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके।
समझ में आ गया?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके।
अब यहां पे एल्गोरिदम्स अलग-अलग हैं। जैसे
कि एक एमडी5 होता है। एसए वन होता है। एसए
256 होती है। एसए 512 होती है। बी क्रिप्ट
होता है। एंड एगन टू ये हैशिंग
एल्गोरिदम्स होती है। अब इनमें कौन सा
एल्गोरिदम आज के टाइम में ट्रू ट्रूली
सिक्योर यू कैन से या ट्रूली नहीं बोलेंगे
या सीधा बोलो कि कौन से एल्गोरििदम आज के
टाइम में सिक्योर है। तो MD5 बिल्कुल
सिक्योर नहीं है। प्लेन MD5 तो बिल्कुल भी
नहीं है। MD5 हैश अह सॉल्टेड MD5 फिर भी
थोड़ा काम चल जाएगा। बट स्टिल प्लेन MD5 इज़
नॉट सिक्योर एट ऑल। एसएचए वन भी सिक्योर
नहीं है। एसएचए 256 इज़ या सिक्योर। एसएचए
512 इज़ सिक्योर। बी क्रिप्ट इज़ वेरी वेरी
सिक्योर। वेरी गुड इंक्रिप हैशिंग फंक्शन
एल्गोरिदम। आर्गन टू इज़ आल्सो वेरी
सिक्योर। यह बहुत वीक होता है। यह ब्रोकन
है। एसए1 जनरली इज नॉट बीइंग यूज्ड। यह
ठीक-ठाक स्ट्रांग है। यह दोनों एसए 256
एंड 512 इज़ स्ट्रांग एंड बी क्रिप्ट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] स्पेशली
पासवर्ड्स के लिए डिज़ किया गया था। तो ये
स्ट्रांग है। एंड ये अभी मॉडर्न स्टैंडर्ड
है आर्गन टू। सो दिस इज़ हाइली स्ट्रांग।
दैट्स इट। तो ये कॉमन हैश एल्गोरिदम्स थे।
एंड इनके कंपैरिजन थे जो मैंने आपको
बताया। ठीक है? अब यहां तक मुझे बताओ जहां
पे हैशिंग क्या होती है? हैशिंग के
प्रॉपर्टीज क्या-क्या हैं? और कॉमन हैश
एल्गोरिदम्स कौन-कौन से हैं? एंड कितने
स्ट्रांग हैं? यहां तक किसी को कोई दिक्कत
आई क्या? यहां तक आपको समझ में आया या
नहीं आया? प्लीज एवरीबॉडी कमेंट्स इन द
चैट। सो दैट आई गेट टू नो कि सभी लोग
एक्टिव हैं। सभी लोग इंटरेस्ट दिखा रहे
हैं। बस स्क्रीन सामने खोल के नहीं बैठे
हैं कि भैया देख लो क्लासेस थोड़ी यहां पे
लाइव की व्यूअरशिप बढ़ा दो। ऐसा नहीं है।
तो प्लीज लेट मी नो इन द चैट सेक्शन। समझ
में आ गया सभी को? एवरीवन अंडरस्टुड टिल
हियर?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके? प्लीज रिस्पॉन्ड। सभी लोग आ जाइए
जल्दी से। मैं आपको गारंटी देता हूं। मैं
मल्टीपल फ्रीक्वेंटली आपके क्लासेस
लाऊंगा। 250 कमेंट्स पहले बोले थे। अब 200
कमेंट्स बोल रहा हूं। कम से कम 200 200
वाओ क्या कॉम्बिनेशन है। 200
कम से कम प्लस कमेंट्स आप अगर आप इस
वीडियो पे या अपकमिंग जितने भी क्लासेस
होंगे उस पे कर देते हैं इस पे भी 200
प्लस तो नेक्स्ट क्लास आपकी आ जाएगी। ठीक
है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यस सभी को समझ में आ गया है।
हां एवरीवन अंडरस्टुड
ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट। ठीक है। ठीक है। बहुत
अच्छी बात है। आई एम ग्लैड कि आपको समझ
में आ रहा है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब यहां पे
है पासवर्ड्स को हैश क्यों किया जाए? ठीक
है? ऐसा इसकी क्या रिक्वायरमेंट है हैश
करने की? पासवर्ड को बिना हैश के भी यूज़
किया जा सकता है क्या? तो पासवर्ड को हैश
करने की रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं। इट्स यह एक
अर्जेंसी है। यह मैंडेटरी है। यू कैन से
बिना हैश पासवर्ड्स को स्टोर करना बेवकूफी
होता है। और ये खैर एक आउट ऑफ स्कोप बातें
हैं। ठीक है? अगर मैं हैश पासवर्ड को हैश
ना करके स्टोर ना हैश पासवर्ड को स्टोर ना
करूं। तो कोई भी अगर ऐसा ना करता हो तो जब
भी आप किसी पोर्टल पे पासवर्ड डालते हैं
वो पासवर्ड जब स्टोर होगी डेटाबेस में तो
उसको क्लियर टेक्स्ट में कोई भी जो
डेटाबेस एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर है या एडमिन है या
कोई भी अगर वो कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो जाता है तो
उसको क्लियरली देख पाएगा तो ये तो लॉजिक
ही नहीं हुआ सिक्योरिटी पर्पस से ये
बिल्कुल वाहियात चीज हो गई तो दैट्स व्हाई
हैशिंग इज़ वेरीेंट अब इमेजिन अ वेबसाइट
स्टोर्स पासवर्ड्स इन प्लेन टेक्स्ट
इमेजिन करो कि पासवर्ड्स को प्लेन टेक्स्ट
में स्टोर कर रहा है जैसे यूजरनेम नितेश
है पासवर्ड नितेश @ 1 2 3 है मान लो इफ
डेटाबेस इज़ हैक्ड अटैकर सीज़ एवरीथिंग जैसा
कि मैंने बोला डेटाबेस हैक होता है या
कॉम्प्रोमाइज होता है जैसे मान लो कोई
एस्क्यू इंजेक्शन अवेलेबिलिटी से
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो जाता है या किसी तरह का
आरसी हो जाता है तो अटैकर को सब दिख
जाएगा। अब अगर [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
उसी वेबसाइट ने क्या स्टोर किया है?
यूजरनेम तो नितेश स्टोर किया है बट हैड्ड
पासवर्ड को स्टोर करा है। तो अगर इवन
डेटाबेस लीक हो जाती है तो अटैकर मस्ट
क्रैक द हैश फर्स्ट। तो अटैकर को पहले हैश
को क्रैक करना पड़ेगा टू गेट द पासवर्ड।
अदरवाइज दे कैन नॉट गेट द पासवर्ड। सिंपल
सा फंडा है। तो ये बिना क्रैकिंग के
पॉसिबल नहीं हो पाएगा। पहले वाले में तो
ईज़ली मिल जा रहा है। दूसरे वाले में उसको
क्रैक करना पड़ेगा। एफर्ट देना पड़ेगा।
बिना क्रैकिंग बिना एफर्ट के वो पासवर्ड
नहीं जान पाएगा। सो दैट्स व्हाई हैशिंग इज़
वेरी वेरीेंट। बट अब एक बड़े प्रॉब्लम के
बारे में बात करते हैं। हैशिंग तो हम समझ
गए। हैशिंग
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
क्या होती है?
कौन-कौन से एल्गोरििदम है? क्यों जरूरी है
हैशिंग? बट इसमें एक बड़ा प्रॉब्लम है।
एंड वह प्रॉब्लम है विदाउट सॉल्टिंग हैशेस
को स्टोर करना। विदाउट सॉल्टिंग। अब देखो
विदाउट सॉल्टिंग यहां पे नाम भी बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग है। सॉल्टिंग। सॉल्ट। सॉल्ट
का मतलब पता है ना सबको क्या होता है भाई?
यह भी नहीं पता। यह बताओ मुझे। डू यू नो
गाइस? व्हाट इज साल्ट? अरे साल्ट पता है
क्या आप लोगों को? साल्ट का हिंदी नॉर्मल
डे टू डे लाइफ में साल्ट सबको पता होगा।
राइट?
हां साल्ट का मतलब ऑब्वियस सी बात है नमक
होता है। ठीक है? नमक होता है। नमक जो हम
खाने में यूज़ करते हैं। नमक का काम क्या
होता है? नमक का काम होता है टेस्ट को
बिल्कुल ही चेंज कर देना। आप कोई वेजिटेबल
बनाते हो, प्रिपेयर करते हो या किसी भी
तरह का फूड प्रिपेयर करते हो, बिना नमक का
बना के देखो। देखो क्या उसमें टेस्ट आएगी।
है ना? अंटिल इट इज़ अ स्वीट
फूड। तो बिना नमक का बना के देखो तो कोई
टेस्ट नहीं। बट जैसे ही उसमें थोड़ा सा
नमक डाल लिया टेस्ट बिल्कुल नॉर्मल या
ओरिजिनल टेस्ट जो आती है ना वो आ जाती है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो नमक हैज़ द
पावर टू चेंज द टेस्ट कंप्लीटली। कभी
ज्यादा डाल दोगे नमक तो ज्यादा अजीब सा हो
जाएगा। नहीं डालोगे तो भी अजीब सा लगेगा।
राइट? सो उसको हम साल्ट बोलते। सो द सेम
कॉनंसेप्ट्स अप्लाई हियर सॉल्टिंग। एक
नॉर्मल सा हैश है। उसमें हम थोड़ा नमक
मिला देंगे। नमक में इच्छ मिला देंगे और
फिर वो और भी ज्यादा टेस्टीियर और भी
ज्यादा स्ट्रांगर हो जाएगा। सॉल्टिंग का
मतलब यही होता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] हैश अलोन इज
नॉट इनफ। मतलब बिना नमक के खाना मजेदार
नहीं है। ठीक है? तो हैशिंग के अंदर
सॉल्टिंग को मिक्स कर दिया जाए तब वो
मजेदार हो जाती है। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
देखो मैंने पहले ही बोला था गाइज़ कि आप
लोग रिस्प वो प्लीज स्पैम मत कीजिए।
बिल्कुल आप हर लैब का हर चीज का मैं
एक्सप्लेन करूंगा। आप बिल्कुल बेफिक्र
रहिए आप लोग एंड यू विल गेट एवरीथिंग। मैं
पहले जो फ्लो में जा रहा हूं उस फ्लो में
आप आइए और उसी फ्लो में रहिए। फिर एक टाइम
पे ऐसा आएगा कि बहुत सारे प्रैक्टिकल्स
बहुत सारी चीजें आएंगी। तो आपको भी मजा उस
टाइम में आएगा बट उस टाइम में तभी मजा
आएगा जब आप अभी के टाइम को यूटिलाइज़ अच्छे
से आपने करा होगा और कांसेप्ट जानकारी
आपने रखी होगी। मैं आपको गारंटी के साथ
बोल रहा हूं कि अगर आपने ये कांसेप्ट्स पे
ध्यान नहीं दिया और और कांसेप्ट्स को समझा
नहीं थ्योरी को नहीं समझा प्रैक्टिकल के
टाइम आपको कुछ नहीं समझ में आने वाला है
और उस टाइम आप मुझे ब्लेम भी करेंगे तो
कोई फायदा नहीं होने वाला है क्योंकि मैं
पहले से ही बार-बार बोल रहा हूं और उस
टाइम हो सकता है कुछ लोग बोलेंगे अरे सर
ये क्या हो रहा है सर दिमाग से ऊपर जा रहा
है सर दिमाग के ऊपर से जा रहा है सर ये
क्या कौन सी क्वेरी डाल रहे हो एसआईएम में
ये क्या चला रहे हो क्वेरी में किस तरीके
से यह रिजल्ट्स यह सामने आउटपुट आ रहे हैं
तो ये दिमाग में आपके चलेगा
तो इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट कि डोंट गो वि अदर
फ्लो और अदर थिंग्स जस्ट गो वि द सेम फ्लो
दैट आई एम गोइंग फॉर यू राइट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है आई थिंक समझ गए होंगे आप
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] हैशिंग अकेले
कुछ भी बेचारा नहीं कर सकता है बिकॉज़ इफ
टू यूज़र्स यूजज़ द सेम पासवर्ड यूजर वन
पासवर्ड वन टू थ्री यूजर टू का भी पासवर्ड
वन टू थ्री है बोथ हैशेस विल बी आइडेंटिकल
तो अगर दो यूजर हैं आप और मैं अगर सेम
पासवर्ड यूज़ कर रहे हैं ना दोनों के हैश
सेम होंगे। तो अटैकर को इंस्टेंटली पता चल
जाएगा कि यह सेम पासवर्ड्स हैं। सिंपल
क्योंकि हैशेस सेम होंगे। तो विदाउट
सॉल्टिंग दो सिमिलर पासवर्ड्स के हैशेस भी
सिमिलर होते हैं। बट अब इसमें मैं आपको
बताता हूं। इसी का फायदा उठा के रेनबो
टेबल अटैक जो है वह किया जाता है या रेनबो
टेबल्स की जो पूरी डायरेक्टरी है या
डेटाबेस है वो बनाया गया। अटैकर क्रिएट
ह्यूज प्रीम्यूटेड टेबल्स। किस तरीके का
टेबल? पासवर्ड और उनके हैस का। ये
प्रीकंप्यू्यूटेड टेबल बनाते हैं जिसको
रेनबो टेबल कहा जाता है। अब आप लोग रिकॉल
कर पा रहे होंगे। मैंने रेनबो टेबल अटैक
के बारे में बताया था लास्ट क्लास में।
बताइए मुझे।
ड आई टेल यू अबाउट रेनबो टेबल अटैक इन द
लास्ट क्लास अगर जो लोग सिंसियर होंगे
उनको पता होगा बताइए मुझे क्या मैंने
बताया था आपको
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके ऋषु थैंक यू
बताया था ना
[खांसने की आवाज़] जी हां रेनबो टेबल अटैक
के बारे में मैंने बताया था इसलिए मैंने
बोला था कि मैं हर डॉट्स को आगे चलके
कनेक्ट करूंगा। हर डॉट्स आपको धीरे-धीरे
कनेक्ट होते हुए दिखेंगे। तो आपको हर एक
टॉपिक समझना है। तो रेनबो टेबल टैक्स
अटैकर क्रिएट करते हैं। जहां पे पासवर्ड्स
होते हैं एक टेबल में एक एक कॉलम में और
एक दूसरे कॉलम में यहां पे उनके हैशेस
होते हैं। ऐसे बहुत बड़ी-बड़ी लिस्टेस
लिस्ट्स होती हैं। रेनबो टेबल्स जिनको हम
बोलते हैं। मैंने रेनबो टेबल्स बताए भी
थे। ओपीए क्रैक की वेबसाइट पे ले जाके कि
सैंड सैंपल रेनबो टेबल्स कैसे वो स्टोर
करके जीबीस में टीबीस में पीबीस में
गीगाबाइट टेराबाइट पेटाबाइट्स में होते
हैं स्टोर अब अगर अटैकर उन रेनबो टेबल्स
के अगेंस्ट
अटैक शुरू कर देता है पासवर्ड के लिए
क्रैकिंग के लिए तो अगर आपका हैश विदाउट
सॉल्टेड है तो इट्स अ हाई चांस कि आपको वो
पासवर्ड आपका जो है वो क्रैक हो जाएगा
रेनबू टेबलबल अटैक से क्योंकि इतनी बड़ी
डेटाबेस होती है कि मैक्सिमम जो कॉमन
पासवर्ड्स होते हैं उनके हैशेस को वहां पे
स्टोर करके रखा जाता है रेनबो टेबल में
होती है बट अगर इन्हीं पासवर्ड्स में मैं
मान लो ये एडमिन 1 2 3 पासवर्ड है। अगर
मैं इसी में एक सॉल्ट जोड़ दूं प्लस करके
मैं मान लो एक सॉल्ट जोड़ देता हूं। साल्ट
मतलब कुछ भी रैंडम स्ट्रिंग मान लो मैंने
यहां पे रैंडम स्ट्रिंग वन ए
एंड @ कुछ भी डाल देता हूं व्हाटएवर
देन यह पूरा का पूरा इनपुट ही चेंज हो जा
रहा है। एंड फॉर दैट रीज़ यहां हमें
कंप्लीटली डिफरेंट हैश देखने को मिलेंगे
जो कि रेनबो टेबल के अंदर अटैक करके नहीं
होंगे। तो इट विल बी वेरी वेरी टफ टू
क्रैक दिस काइंड ऑफ़ पासवर्ड्स और दिस
काइंड ऑफ़ हैशेस विथ रेनबो टेबल अटैक।
सिंपल सा फंडा है। इफ डेटाबेस हैश मैचेस
वन इन टेबल पासवर्ड इंस्टेंटली क्रैक्ड।
सिंपल सा फंडा है कि अगर डेटाबेस को जो भी
हैश है डेटाबेस से अगर वो मैच कर देता है
टेबल में तो पासवर्ड क्रैक हो जाएगी। दिस
इज व्हाई MD5 SSH1 आर डेंजरस क्योंकि ये
बहुत ही लो लेवल के पासवर्ड्स मैकेनिज्म
मतलब है एल्गोरििदम है जो क्रैक हो चुके
हैं तो यूज़ में नहीं लिए जाते हैं। तो इस
तरीके से रेनबो टेबल अटैक से पासवर्ड्स को
क्रैक कर लिया जाएगा। बट वो तभी जब
सॉल्टिंग नहीं होगी। क्योंकि अगर सॉर्टिंग
नहीं यूज हो रही है तो वह बहुत ही ज्यादा
वनरेबल पासवर्ड है। बहुत ही ईजीली
क्रैकेबल पासवर्ड हो सकता है अगर डेटाबेस
में रेनबो टेबल की आ जाती है अटैकर के।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सॉल्टिंग
होती क्या है एग्जैक्टली?
एंड क्यों रेनबो टेबल अटैक जो है वो
सक्सेसफुल नहीं होगा। अगर आप सॉल्टेड
पासवर्ड सॉल्टेड हैश जो है वो स्टोर कर
रहे हैं डेटाबेस में या कोई भी डेटाबेस
ऐसी डेटाबेस है किसी कंपनी की किसी
वेबसाइट की जो पासवर्ड को स्टोर जो कर रहा
है हैशेस को वो सॉल्टेड हैशेस#श
प्लस साल्ट इसको स्टोर कर रहा है उसको कैक
करना कंपेरेटिवली बहुत मुश्किल है नियर टू
इंपॉसिबल है विथ अ रिनबू टेबलबल अटैक
काइंड ऑफ़ थिंग्स राइट अब सॉल्ट क्या होता
है रैंडम वैल्यू एडेड टू पासवर्ड बिफोर है
मतलब मतलब हैशिंग करने के पहले ही रैंडम
वैल्यू ऐड कर दो। अब खुद सोचो ना एक
प्रीीीडफाइंड पैटर्न में अगर कुछ हो तो उस
पे तो ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक चला लो। उस पे
डिफरेंट पासवर्ड अटैक्स चला लो। वो काम
करने के चांसेस भी हैं। बट कोई ऐसी चीज है
जिसमें रैंडम कुछ भी वैल्यू ऐड कर सक कर
कर सकते हैं। और उसको कुछ भी डाल के बनाया
गया है तो कंपेरेटिवली उसको कंप्यूट करना
बहुत मुश्किल हो जाएगा। मैं कुछ भी डाल
सकता हूं। मैं तो यार @ डॉट स्टार कुछ भी
डाल दूंगा। तो ऐसा पैटर्न बनाना तो बहुत
मुश्किल है। ऐसी वर्ड लिस्ट या ऐसी
डिक्शनरी या वैसा एक टेबल बनाना। दैट्स
व्हाई सॉल्टिंग इज़ देयर। सो रैंडम
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] वैल्यू ऐड कर
दिए जाते हैं बिफोर हैशिंग। हैशिंग के
पहले। तो इंस्टेड ऑफ़ हैशिंग पासवर्ड 1 2 3
नॉर्मली पासवर्ड 1 2 3 को हैश कर दिया
जाता था। जब तक सॉल्टिंग नहीं था। अब क्या
होगा? पासवर्ड 1 2 3 जो पासवर्ड हमारा है
उसमें रैंडम सॉल्ट को ऐड कर दिया जाएगा और
उसके बाद उसको हैश किया जाएगा। और स्टोर
किया जाएगा। यह एक मोर सिक्योर
अप्रोच है बाय सॉल्टिंग द आपका पासवर्ड
बिफोर इवन हैशिंग। हैशिंग से भी पहले। तो
अगर [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यूजर का पासवर्ड मान लो पासवर्ड 1 2 3 है।
इसमें एक साल्ट हमने जनरेट किया x7k9
पीएल2 रैंडम स्ट्रिंग रैंडम डिजिट्स रैंडम
अल्फाबेट्स।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब सिस्टम का जो हैश है वह किसको हैश
जनरेट किसका हैश जनरेट करेगा पासवर्ड 1 2
3 x7 k9 pl2 ये अब पूरी की पूरी एक तरह से
ये पासवर्ड होगी आपकी द पासवर्ड इज़ नॉट
दिस वन लेट्स सपोज़ देखो जब आप पासवर्ड
टाइप करना होगा तो आप पासवर्ड बस यही टाइप
करोगे पासवर्ड 1 2 3 टू लॉग इन ऑन वेब
पोर्टल से या कहीं पे भी बट बैकग्राउंड
में ये ऑलरेडी इसके साथ एक रैंडम स्ट्रिंग
ऐड हो गया है जिसको साल्ट बोलेंगे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] और इस पूरी
स्ट्रिंग की अब हैश जनरेट हो रही है जो कि
डेटाबेस में यहां पे सेव होगी फॉर
सिक्योरिटी रीज़ंस।
दैट्स इट। सो अनदर यूजर विद द सेम पासवर्ड
गेट्स डिफरेंट साल्ट डिफरेंट हैश। ये एक
खूबी है इसकी। अब मान लो कोई एक और यूजर
है। कोई एक और यूजर है। ऐसा भी हो ऐसा
होगा। सो लेट मी मेक यू अंडरस्टैंड विद
दिस एग्जांपल। मान लो यहां पे यूजर वन है।
इसका
पासवर्ड
डिफ्रॉनिक्स 1 2 3 है। ठीक है? और यूजर टू
है। इसका भी पासवर्ड
डिफ्रॉनिक्स 1 2 3 ही है। सेम पासवर्ड है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ये सेम पासवर्ड है। अब इसमें दो सिनेरियो
होंगे। सीन वन क्या सिनेरियो है? सीन वन
में विदाउट सॉल्ट। विदाउट साल्ट होंगे। तो
यहां पे हैशिंग होगी।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हैशिंग में#श क्या निकल के आएगा? मान लो
वन 2
मान लो ये हैश निकल के आया इसका मान लो और
यूजर टू के लिए भी सीन वन होगा
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] जिसमें विदाउट
सॉल्ट होगी। विदाउट सॉल्टिंग इसको
सॉल्टिंग मैं कर देता हूं। सो विदाउट
सॉल्टिंग।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सो इसका जो हैशिंग होगा सॉरी हैश हैश होगा
इसका जो हैश होगा ये भी बिल्कुल सेम हैश
होगा [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ये एक
सिनेरियो है ठीक अब सेम सिनेरियो को थोड़ा
चेंज करते हैं। अब सीन टू में क्या आते
हैं?
विद सॉल्टिंग। अब विद सॉल्टिंग कर देते
हैं। तो अब इसका जो हैश होगा अब विद
सॉल्टिंग में यहां पर सॉल्ट क्या रैंडम
वैल्यू क्या हम इसमें ऐड कर रहे हैं? मान
लो मैंने
मैंने ये रैंडम वैल्यू ऐड कर दिया। ठीक
है? इसके सीन टू में और सेम इसके सीन टू
में
मैंने विद सॉल्टिंग करा और यहां पे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] जो मैं सॉल्ट या
जो मैं वैल्यू डाल रहा हूं ये मैं डिफरेंट
एक वैल्यू डालूंगा 4 5 6 एंड देन q
डब्ल्यू ई आर ऐसे मैं डालूंगा। तो अब देखो
पासवर्ड सेम है। पासवर्ड इज सेम
डिफ्रॉनिक्स 1 2 3 डिफ्रॉनिक्स 1 2 3 पहले
सीन में विदाउट सॉर्टिंग करा हैश बिल्कुल
सेम आई दोनों की सिंपल ये बिल्कुल सिक्योर
नहीं है। रेनबो टेबल अटैक से आराम से
क्रैक किया जा सकता है। एक यूजर का क्रैक
होगा। तो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] उस के
सिमिलर जितने भी पासवर्ड्स जितने भी यूजर
के होंगे सबके क्रैक हो गए। एक तरह से। अब
सीन टू में विद सॉल्टिंग मैंने इस पासवर्ड
के साथ एक रैंडम स्ट्रिंग ऐड करा 1 2 3 एस
डी डब्ल्यू और दूसरे पासवर्ड के साथ मैंने
रैंडम स्ट्रिंग ऐड करा 4 5 6 क्यू डब्ल्यू
ई आर टी ये मैंने ऐड किया तो अब जो सॉल्ट
यहां पे अब जो हैश आएगा
ये इसका जो हैश आएगा वो कुछ इस तरीके का
हैश आएगा एक और जो सीन टू का हैश अब आएगा
वो भी बिल्कुल ही रैंडम हैश आएंगे
वो भी बिल्कुल डिफरेंट रैंडम हैश आएंगे तो
सॉर्टिंग के बाद इसकी हैश वैल्यू कुछ और
है और इसकी हैश वैल्यू कुछ और है बट
डिफरेंट हैशेस तो है पासवर्ड हमेशा सेम है
पासवर्ड दोनों का सेम है बट सॉल्टिंग कर
दी तो हैशेस जो है वो हमारे को डिफरेंट
मिल गई तो ये ज्यादा सिक्योर हो गया दोनों
यूजर के लिए एंड रेनबो टेबल अटैक से इसको
क्रैक इसको क्रैक कर पाना नियर टू
इंपॉसिबल हो जाता है। सो दैट्स व्हाई इट्स
वेरी वेरी यूज़फुल जिसको हम सॉल्टिंग बोलते
हैं। ठीक है? तो अन जो दूसरा जो यूजर है
सेम पासवर्ड के साथ उसको डिफरेंट साल्ट
मिल जाएगा। इनपुट डिफरेंट रैंडम स्ट्रिंग
एंड डिफरेंट हैश मिल जाएगा। ठीक है?
इतना समझ में आ गया आप सभी को?
डॉगेश [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] भाई। हां
जी। डॉगेश भाई का जलवा है अपना अपनी
सोसाइटी में। डॉगेश भाई जलवा भी कहते रहते
हैं। चलिए बता दीजिए मुझे। इतना समझ में
आया सभी को? जस्ट लेट मी नो।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एवरीवन अंडरस्टैंडिंग
ईजीली समझ में आ रहा है ना आपको गाइस?
लाइक काइंड ऑफ कि आपको
बहुत टफ टाइप तो नहीं लगता ना? क्योंकि
मैं देखो मैं बहुत कोशिश करता हूं कि अह
जितना ईजी लेमन अह तरीके से बता सकूं वैसे
बताने की कोशिश करता हूं। ठीक है? सो आई
होप कि आप सबको थोड़ा इजी लगता होगा।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एकदम अच्छे से समझ में आ गया।
या वेलकम गौरव
ओके नमन बढ़िया ओके आदित्य जेडी कोडर ओके
ब्रदर
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है।
ओके गॉट इट। ठीक है। चलिए। अरे तो
ऑथेंटिकेशन के टाइम पे हर यूजर का हर यूजर
का हैश स्टोर है ना। एक पर्टिकुलर उस यूजर
का एक अलग हैश स्टर्ड है। उस सेशन का एक
यूजर का अलग स्ट है। दूसरे यूजर का दूसरा
स्टोर्ड होगा। ऑब्वियस सी बात है। तो
ऑथेंटिकेशन में तो कोई इशू नहीं आ रही है।
ओके।
ओके। ठीक है। अब यहां पे आते हैं। व्हाई
सॉल्टिंग इज़ वेरी पावरफुल? क्यों इतना ये
पावरफुल चीज है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सो देखो इवन इफ 100 यूजर्स यूज़ द सेम
पासवर्ड। अगर 100 यूज़र्स भी सेम पासवर्ड
यूज़ करते हैं तो बिना
सॉल्टिंग के सेम हैश मिलेगा। सॉल्टिंग के
बाद सारे हैशेस डिफरेंट होंगे। जैसा मैंने
पहले बताया सेम चीज। अटैकर कैन नॉट यूज़
रेनबो टेबल्स इफेक्टिवली। रेनबो टेबल्स का
यूज़ नहीं कर सकते अटैक करने के लिए। दे
मस्ट ब्रूड फ़ोर्स ईच हैश इंडिविजुअली।
उनको हर एक हैश को इंडिविजुअली ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स करना पड़ेगा। एंड दिस इज़ अ वेरी
हैक्टिक। दिस इज़ अ वेरी टाइम टेकिंग एंड
दिस कैन बी अ नियर टू इंपॉसिबल टास्क।
क्योंकि हैश के साथ सॉल्ट रैंडम
स्ट्रिंग्स होते हैं और उसमें हम कुछ भी
ऐड कर सकते हैं। तो उसको ब्रूट फ़ोर्स कर
पाना वो बहुत ही मुश्किल काम है। दिस
मेक्स क्रैकिंग एक्सट्रीमली एक्सपेंसिव
एंड बहुत बहुत हार्ड। एक्सपेंसिव भी और
बहुत हार्ड भी बना देता है। अब सॉल्ट को
कैसे स्टोर किया जाता है? क्या
प्रोसेस होता है? यह भी समझ लीजिए। हो
सकता है आपको इससे और ज्यादा क्लेरिटी मिल
जाए। डेटाबेस जो है किसी भी वेब एप्लीकेशन
का, किसी भी वेबसाइट का डेटाबेस जो होता
है वो तीन चीजों को मेनली स्टोर करता है।
एक यूजरनेम होती है। देखो और भी चीजें
स्टोर होती है। बट यहां पे मैं सिर्फ
पासवर्ड के कॉन्टेक्स्ट में बात कर रहा
हूं। यूजरनेम होता है, साल्ट होता है और
हैशेस होते हैं। ठीक है? तीनों चीज़ व्हेन
यूजर लॉग्स इन जब यूजर लॉग इन करता है,
सिस्टम रिट्राइव्स द साल्ट। सिस्टम क्या
करता है? साल्ट को रिट्रीव करता है। जो
ऑथेंटिकेशन का आप पूछ रहे थे अभी अह राइट
नाउ अह समवन वाज़ आस्किंग अबाउट ऑथेंटिकेशन
कि ऑथेंटिकेशन कैसे ये काम करती है? आपका
भी आंसर इसमें मिल जाएगा। तो जब भी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
जब भी आप लॉगिन करते हैं, जब भी एज अ यूजर
कोई भी यूजर लॉग इन करता है, सो सिस्टम
सबसे पहले साल्ट को रिट्रीव करता है।
सिस्टम रिट्रीव्स द साल्ट। ऐड्स साल्ट टू
एंटर्ड पासवर्ड। जो पासवर्ड है एंटर्ड
आपने किया था उसमें वो साल्ट ऐड कर देता
है। हैश इट एंड कंपेयर्स विद द स्टर्ड#श।
तो जब फर्स्ट टाइम आप फर्स्ट टाइम किसी
वेबसाइट पे अपना अकाउंट क्रिएट कर रहे
होते हैं, पासवर्ड क्रिएट कर रहे होते हैं
तो फर्स्ट टाइम ही आपके पासवर्ड का
सॉल्टेड हैश जो है वो जनरेट हो के स्टोर
हो जाती है डेटाबेस में। तो जब नेक्स्ट
टाइम से आप लॉग इन करते हैं तो ये प्रोसेस
फॉलो होता है जिसमें
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आप जो साल्ट है
उसको रिटाइव किया जाता है। साल्ट को
एंटर्ड पासवर्ड में ऐड किया जाता है और
उसको हैश किया जाता है और फिर स्टर्ड हैश
से मैच किया जाता है। एज सिंपल एज दैट
यूजर स्पेसिफिक साल्ट्स जो है वो स्टोर
किए जाते हैं एंड उसी साल्ट को रिट्राइव
किया जाता है। ठीक है? ये समझ में आ गया
होगा। जिनका भी क्वेश्चन था कुछ किसी ने
क्वेश्चन पूछा था।
शुभम ने शायद पूछा था। तो आई थिंक शुभम
आपका यह जो जो भी क्वेरी था वह आपको समझ
में आ गया होगा। ठीक है? कि हर स्पेसिफिक
यूजर स्पेसिफिक साल्ट को स्टोर कर लिया
जाता है। और जब दोबारा लॉगिन होता है तो
उसी साल्ट को रिटाइव करके पासवर्ड के साथ
ऐड करके हैश करके और स्टर्ड हैश से कंपेयर
किया जाता है। ठीक है? समझ में आ गया होगा
इतना। बहुत इजी वे में मैंने बताया है कि
अगर वो मैच कर जाता है तो लॉग इन
सक्सेसफुल हो जाएगी। मैच नहीं करता है तो
लॉग इन सक्सेसफुल नहीं होगी। इस पूरे
प्रोसेस को समझने में कोई दिक्कत आई किसी
को इस प्रोसेस को क्योंकि यह बहुत इजी और
बहुत सिंपल से मैंने तरीके से बताया है।
कॉम्प्लेक्स प्रोसेस है यह। आपको मैं इली
मैं आपको एक चीज बताता हूं। मैं आपको बहुत
इजी वे में समझाता हूं। बट बहुत सारे ऐसे
कांसेप्ट्स होते हैं। बहुत कॉम्प्लेक्स
होते हैं। अगर आप बुक्स में इंटरनेट पे
कहीं पे आप पढ़ेंगे जाके इन्हीं
प्रोसेससेस को। हो सकता है आप में से कई
लोगों के दिमाग में जल्दी आए ना बैठे ना।
क्योंकि वो एक्चुअली होता कॉम्प्लेक्स है।
बट मैं ब्रेकडाउन करके इजी नॉर्मल
लैंग्वेज में बताता हूं ताकि आपको समझ में
आ जाए।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके गॉट इट। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यस यस यस। साल्ट वेबसाइट्स जो होती हैं वो
आपकी रैंडम स्ट्रिंग्स जनरेट करके क्रिएट
करती हैं यूजर स्पेसिफिक जो आपकी
वेबसाइट्स हैं। आप साल्ट के स्ट्रिंग्स को
नहीं लिखते हो। यू डोंट राइट साल्ट
स्ट्रिंग्स। आप पासवर्ड नॉर्मल पासवर्ड ही
लिखते हो। जैसे आपको पासवर्ड सेट करना है
डिफ्रॉनिक्स 1 2 3 तो आप डिफ्रॉनिक्स 1 2
3 ही पासवर्ड सेट करोगे। जब आप लॉग इन
साइन अप करोगे तब उस टाइम पे आपको नहीं
साल्ट लिखनी है। जैसे ही आप टाइप करके आप
साइन अप कर रहेगे तो ये वेब जो आपका
वेबसाइट है वेब एप्लीकेशन है वो साल्ट उस
यूजर स्पेसिफिक साल्ट को जनरेट करके स्टोर
करता है। एंड आगे चलके हैस को मैच करने के
लिए यूज़ में लेता है। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] समझ में आ
गया?
बढ़िया बात है। जगतगुरु
गॉट इट? जिनका क्वेश्चन था उनको भी समझ
में आ गया होगा। यस सर आई लव द वे यू टीच।
थैंक यू ब्रदर।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सर मैं तो साइबर सिक्योरिटी एंट्री के लिए
एसओसी सीख रहा। मुझे बनना तो रेड टीमर है
पर स्टार्टिंग में रेड टीमिंग जॉब मिलना
बहुत मुश्किल है। इसलिए पहले एसओसी
एनालिस्ट करूं बाद में रेड टीमिंग।
बिल्कुल सही बोला आपने। एंड बिल्कुल सही
अप्रोच भी है। थोड़ी सी मुश्किल होती तो
है
रेड टीमिंग में इनिशियली जाने में। ऐसा
नहीं है कि बिल्कुल बिल्कुल नहीं जा सकते
या बिल्कुल इंपॉसिबल है। जाते हैं बिल्कुल
फ्रेशर्स भी जाते हैं लोग। बट हां अगर
एसओसी के थ्रू जा रहे हैं तो थोड़ा
कंपेरेटिवली ईजी हो जाता है। घुसना इजी हो
जाता है। एंड आप अगर रेड टीमिंग भी करने
जा रहे हैं ना तो एसओसी के अगर आपके पास
कांसेप्ट्स हैं, नॉलेज है तो ये आपके लिए
बेनिफिशियल ही होगा। आपके लिए कोई लॉस
मेकिंग चीज नहीं है यह। इट्स अ बेनिफिशियल
थिंग, राइट?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़]
ओके। तो, यह आपको समझ में आ गया होगा कि
सॉल्टिंग क्यों पावरफुल है। अब मैं यहां
पे आपको हैशिंग वर्सेस इंक्रिप्शन का एक
छोटा सा ओवरव्यू देता हूं। मैंने आपको
पहले ही बोला था इंक्रिप्शन अलग होती है,
हैशिंग अलग होती है। हालांकि हम
इंक्रिप्शन के बारे में अभी पढ़ने वाले
हैं, जानने वाले हैं आने वाले अभी
स्लाइड्स के अंदर में बट स्टिल मैं आपको
थोड़ा ओवरव्यू देता हूं। बाद में और भी
अच्छे से इसको एक्सप्लेन
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] करूंगा। देखो
यहां [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] में फीचर्स
की बात कर रहे हैं हम पहले कॉलम में।
दूसरे में हैशिंग
में होती है कि नहीं वो और इंक्रिप्शन में
होती है कि नहीं? ये सब बातें
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सबसे पहले
फीचर की हम जब बात करते हैं तो क्या ये
रिवर्सिबल फीचर जो होता है वो किस में
होती है? हैशिंग में रिवर्सिबल फीचर नहीं
होता। इंक्रिप्शन में रिवर्सिबल होता है।
यानी अगर कोई डेटा आपने इंक्रिप्ट कर दिया
है तो उसको डिक्रिप्ट भी किया जा सकता है।
यू कैन डिक्रिप्ट इट। अगर आपने किसी प्लेन
टेक्स्ट को इंक्रिप्ट करके सफर टेक्स्ट या
इंक्रिप्टेड टेक्स्ट में कन्वर्ट किया है
तो यू कैन गेट बैक द प्लेन टेक्स्ट एज वेल
बाय डिक्रिप्टिंग दैट। पासवर्ड्स के लिए
यूज़ में लिया जाता है। हैशिंग। पासवर्ड्स
के लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता है। इंक्रिप्शन
नहीं लिए यूज़ में। इंक्रिप्शन जो है नहीं
लिया जाता है। कीज़ की नीड होती है। तो
हैशिंग में कोई कीज़ की नीड नहीं होती है।
बट इंक्रिप्शन में कीज़ की नीड हो नीड होती
है। जिसको पब्लिक कीज़ प्राइवेट कीज़ हम
बोलते हैं। पर्पस क्या है? इंटीग्रिटीज को
इंटीग्रिटी को बचाना हैशिंग का काम है और
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी को सेफगार्ड करना
इंक्रिप्शन का काम है। अब मैंने आपको पहले
ही बोला हुआ है देखो हर एक छोटे-छोटे
कांसेप्ट्स एक दूसरे से कनेक्ट होते हैं।
डॉट्स कनेक्ट होते हैं और जब डॉट्स कनेक्ट
होने लगेंगे और आप सोचने लगोगे उन डॉट्स
के ऊपर तो आपको हैकिंग के अंदर में एथिकल
हैकिंग के अंदर में एसओसी के अंदर में
बहुत मजा आने वाला है और बहुत मजा आएगा
भी। अब यहां पे हैशिंग का एक सिंपल सा
डेफिनेशन आप बना सकते हो। इन साइबर
सिक्योरिटी
अ मेथड अ प्रोसेस
ऑफ कन्वर्ज़ ऑफ डेटा कन्वर्ज़ ऑफ़ डेटा इंटू
अ फिक्स्ड लेंथ स्ट्रिंग
टू सेफगार्ड द इंटीग्रिटी
इज़ नोन ऐज़ हैशिंग। यह जब आपने इससे
स्टेटमेंट बोला तो यह बहुत एक अच्छा
इंटरव्यू पॉइंट ऑफ व्यू से बहुत एक अच्छा
डेफिनेशन होगा। हैशिंग का। अगर कोई आपसे
पूछ देता है तो आप हैशिंग का ये वाला ये
वाला भी आप बोल सकते हो। और हैश इज़ अ वन
वे मैथमेटिकल ट्रांसफॉर्मेशन ऑफ़ डेटा इंटू
अ फिक्स्ड लेंथ स्ट्रिंग। अब इसमें आप एक
ऐड अगर कर दो कि हैश इज अ वन वे मैथमेटिकल
ट्रांसफॉर्मेशन ऑफ डाटा इनू अ फिक्स्ड
लेंथ स्ट्रिंग इंटू अ फिक्स्ड लेंथ
स्ट्रिंग टू सेफगार्ड द इंटीग्रिटी ऑफ़ द
डेटा
तो आपका यह आंसर बहुत परफेक्ट और इंटरव्यू
फ्रेंडली आंसर हो जाएगा। आप समझ रहे हो इस
चीज को? दोनों में अंतर है। नॉर्मल एक
बंदा आंसर कर रहा है वो और एक आप
इंटीग्रिटी को अगर उसमें घुसा दो तो ये
बहुत ही अच्छा टेक्निकल आंसर हो जाता है।
इंटरव्यू फ्रेंडली आंसर हो जाता है। एंड
यहां पे कई अ कई ऐसे यहां पे लोग होंगे जो
एसओसीस
अ एसओसी डोमेन में होंगे। वो इस बात से
शायद एग्री करते होंगे कि इंटरव्यू में
आपका आंसर बहुत डिपेंड कर। आपका जो आंसर
है अब वे ऑफ़ आंसरिंग बहुत ज्यादा मैटर
करता है टू गेट हायर्ड। क्योंकि आपके जैसे
हजारों कैंडिडेट्स उस इंटरव्यू के लिए
जाते हैं एंड इंटरव्यूअर के ऊपर बड़ा लोड
होता है कि किसको हायर करें। तो स्पेसिफिक
अगर कोई बहुत डिटेल में जाके एंड अच्छे से
एक्सप्लेन कर रहा है तो उसको वो डेफिनेटली
चांस देते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
गॉट इट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] या
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे कुछ
यस क्रिप्टोग्राफिक टेक्निक्स आर यूज्ड
बिल्कुल सही बात है।
[खांसने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके। इंक्रिप्शन में इंटीग्रिटी नहीं
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी को प्रोटेक्ट किया जाता
है। सेफगार्ड द कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी दोनों
में अंतर यहीं पे आप समझ जाएंगे। देखो
आप सबको इंटीग्रिटी और कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी
वर्ड से क्या याद आ रहा है? ऑनेस्टली
बताइए मुझे चैट बॉक्स में। सभी लोग आंसर
कीजिए। लेट्स सी हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू आर
रिकॉलिंग रिमेंबरिंग व्हाट आई एम ट्राइंग
टू से आफ्टर इंटीग्रिटी एंड
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी वर्ड। इससे आपको क्या
याद आ रहा है?
एथिकल हॉकिंग [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] का
कौन सा कांसेप्ट याद आ रहा है?
बताइए इंटीग्रिटी और कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी को
देख के व्हाट यू आर रिमेंबरिंग?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़] बिल्कुल सही। बिल्कुल
सही। सीआईए ट्रायड सीआईए ट्रायड जिन्होंने
अभी सीआईए ट्रायड बोला या सोचा
कांग्रेचुलेशंस। आप काफी कांसेप्ट्स पे
ऑलरेडी अच्छे हैं। काफी अच्छा कर रहे हैं।
ऐसे ही आप आगे बढ़ते रहिए एंड यू विल गुड
यू विल डू ग्रेट इन द नियर फ्यूचर। सीआईए
ट्राइड जहां पे कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी
अवेलेबिलिटी और इंटीग्रिटी की बात होती है
और हैकिंग हम एथिकल हैकिंग की जब बात करते
हैं तो एथिकल हैकिंग का मतलब सिंपल सा
होता है अ प्रोसेस
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] व्हिच मेक्स
सेफ व्हिच सेफगार्ड द सीआईएस यानी
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी इंटीग्रिटी और
अवेलेबिलिटी को बचाना ही एथिकल हैकिंग
होता है। सिंपल सा फंडा है। तो हैशिंग
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] में ये
इंटीग्रिटी को बचा रहे हैं एंड इंक्रिप्शन
में कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी को बता बचा रहे हैं।
इंटीग्रिटी का मतलब है कि डेटा जो एक डाटा
है उसमें किसी तरह का चेंजिंग नहीं है।
किसी भी तरह का ट्रांसफॉर्मेशन
मलिशियस ट्रांसफॉर्मेशन नहीं है। जैसा
डाटा था वैसा ही डेटा अभी भी है। जिस
तरीके से डेटा सेंडर के पास से चला था
रिसीवर के पास वैसा ही रिसीव हुआ है। किसी
भी तरह का उसमें किसी भी तरह की किसी भी
तरह का चेंज नहीं है। किसी भी तरह का
ट्रांसफॉर्मेशन नहीं है डेटा के अंदर में।
किसी भी तरह का टपरिंग नहीं है डेटा के
अंदर में। ठीक है? तो ये इंटीग्रिटी होता
है। कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी का मतलब होता है कि
डेटा जिसके लिए बना है उसी को मिली है।
जिसके लिए वो डेटा बनी हुई है या डेटा
जिसके लिए
जिसको [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] मिलनी
चाहिए उसी को मिली है। यह
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी कहलाता है जो हम
इंक्रिप्शन में देखते हैं। पासवर्ड शुड
नेवर बी इंक्रिप्टेड। दे शुड बी हैज़्ड
प्लस सॉल्टेड। पासवर्ड को इंक्रिप्ट नहीं
करना चाहिए। पासवर्ड इंक्रिप्ट अह पासवर्ड
इंक्रिप्शन इज़ नॉट अ कॉनंसेप्ट नॉट अ गुड
कॉनंसेप्ट बट पासवर्ड हैशिंग एंड सॉर्टिंग
इज़ द कॉनंसेप्ट एंड इट शुड बी डन।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ठीक है?
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल।
अब एसओसी पर्सपेक्टिव से जब हम देखते हैं,
व्हाई यू मस्ट अंडरस्टैंड दिस? बिकॉज़ आप
एसओसी एल वन के लिए ही पढ़ाई कर रहे हैं।
तो एसओसी का पर्सपेक्टिव देखना बहुत जरूरी
है। तो, पहले लेफ्ट वाले पोर्शन में आते
हैं यहां पे। एंड यहां पे मैं ड्यूरिंग
इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस की बात कर रहा हूं। जब
ड्यूरिंग इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस हो रहा है उस
केस में क्या है? इफ डेटाबेस लीक्ड यू
मस्ट असेस अगर डेटाबेस कोई लीक होती है तो
एज अ एसोसिएट एल एल1 आपको क्या असेस करना
चाहिए। वाज़ हैशिंग यूज़्ड? आपको यह जानना
है। आपको यह खुद से पूछना है। क्या हैशिंग
यूज़ हुई है? वाज़ सॉल्टिंग यूज़्ड? क्या
सॉल्टिंग यूज़ हुई थी? व्हिच एल्गोरिदम कौन
सा एल्गोरिदम यूज़ हुआ था? वाज़ इट
बिक्रिप्ड और जस्ट MD5? कोई स्ट्रांग
एल्गोरिदम यूज़ हुआ था या एक नॉर्मल वीक
एल्गोरिदम यूज़ हुआ था? यह एज अ एसोसियल वन
आपको खुद से पूछना है। इफ वीक हैशिंग हाई
रिस्क ऑफ क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग लेटर अगर
वीक हैशेस यूज़ हुए हैं तो बाद में
क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग हो सकते हैं।
क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग का एक छोटा सा बताइए
मुझे चैट में। मैंने आपको क्या बताया था।
पता नहीं कितने लोगों को याद है इसके बारे
में। क्रेडिट तभी मैं बोला था कि हर एक
कांसेप्ट को छोटी-छोटी चीजों को समझना है।
नहीं तो फिर आगे कुछ नहीं समझ में आएगा।
फिर आप बोलोगे सर क्या बता रहे हो? राइट?
तो जो ऑलरेडी कर रहे हैं कवर ना वो तो
उनको तो सब समझ में आएगा और अभी भी समझ
में आ रहा होगा। बट जो ऐसे नहीं कर रहे
होंगे गारंटी बोल रहा हूं मैं वो दिमाग से
ऊपर जाएगा। क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग के बारे
में मैंने पहले ही बताया था इस वर्ड के
बारे में। मुझे थोड़ा सा शॉर्ट में चैट
में बताइए कि मैंने जो बताया था उसके बारे
में थोड़ा सा इंट्रो क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग
का दे दीजिए कि क्या होता है।
[खांसने की आवाज़]
बताइए [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
करेक्ट बिल्कुल सही बोला। सो यहां पे
कुछ कुछ लोगों ने आंसर सही करा है। बाकी
बहुत सारे लोगों ने आंसर गलत करा है। कुछ
भी बोल रहे हैं वो। यही फर्क हो जाता है।
एंड इसलिए मैं आपको बोलता हूं कि एक-एक
चीज पे फोकस तो करना ही है। साथ में
रिवीजन भी करना है। अगर आप सिर्फ ये लाइव
क्लासेस देख के उसके बाद सोच रहे हैं कि
बस हो गया इतना ही करना है और रिवीजन नहीं
कर रहे हैं रिकॉर्डेड वीडियो वापस से देख
के नोट्स नहीं बना रहे हैं, पॉइंट्स नहीं
लिख रहे हैं। टास्क जो मैं दे रहा हूं
जिसमें की पॉइंट्स को एक्सप्लोर करना है,
खुद से उनके बारे में पढ़ना है, वो नहीं
कर रहे हैं तो ये अधूरा रह जाएगा आपका।
मैं आपको पहले ही बोल रहा हूं। तो प्लीज
ऐसा मत कीजिए। अभी भी आपके पास चांसेस
हैं। अभी नौ क्लासेस ही हुए हैं। आगे चलके
25 30 क्लासेस हो जाएंगे। फिर आप उस चीज
को कवर ही नहीं कर पाएंगे स्टार्टिंग से।
तो अभी आपके पास चांसेस है गैब द
अपोरर्चुनिटी।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है?
बिल्कुल। लीक्ड डेटा से क्या होती है?
लीक्ड डेटा से बिल्कुल। रिट्रीवल ऑफ लीडक्
डेटा फ्रॉम डेटा ब्रीचेस बाय अटैक। लीग
डेटा से या जो भी लीग पासवर्ड्स हैं उनके
थ्रू जो है अटैक्स को मल्टीपल यूज़र्स पे
अटैक्स करना। अगर एक यूजर का मान लो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] पर्टिकुलर एक
डेटाबेस लीकेज हुई है तो उस पासवर्ड को ही
मल्टीपल यूजर के अगेंस्ट में यूज करना
क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग कहलाता है और उसी
अटैक को यहां पे ल्च किया जा सकता है अगर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] कुछ डेटाबेस लीक
इस तरीके से हुई है या वीक हैशिंग यूज़ हुई
है तो अब यहां पे बात करते हैं रियल अटैक
सिनेरियो को हम यहां पे देखते हैं इस राइट
पैन में रियल अटैक सिनेरियो एक देखते हैं
एंड उसका रूट कॉज फाइंड करने की कोशिश
करते हैं। सो कंपनी स्टोर्स पासवर्ड्स इन
MD5 विदाउट साल्ट। MD5 में स्टोर कर लेता
है कंपनी। सॉल्ट नहीं करता है। सॉल्टिंग
नहीं करता है। डेटाबेस ब्रीच हो जाती है।
अटैकर क्रैक्स हैशेस इन मिनट। अटैकर हैशेस
को मिनट्स में क्रैक कर देते हैं। MD5 यूज़
हो रहा है। क्योंकि यूज़र्स रीयूज़ सेम
पासवर्ड्स ऑन। अब जो यूज़र्स हैं उन्होंने
उन्हीं पासवर्ड को ईमेल पे भी यूज़ किया
है। वीpए लॉगिन को भी यूज़ किए। वीpए लॉगिन
के लिए भी यूज़ करा है। बैंकिंग के लिए भी
यूज़ करा है। मैसिव क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग
कैंपेन बिगिंस। अब एक कैंपेन स्टार्ट होगा
क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग का जहां पर लीक्ड
पासवर्ड्स से मल्टीपल यूज़र्स को सॉरी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
मल्टीपल यूज़र्स को टारगेट किया जाएगा
क्योंकि हैशेस क्रैक हो चुके हैं। पासवर्ड
मिल चुका है। तो अब क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग
अटैक स्टार्ट होगा और एसओसी क्या देखेगा
भैया? हमारा जो एल1 बैठा हुआ है सिस्टम के
सामने वो क्या देखेगा? लॉगिन अटेम्प्ट्स
फ्रॉम मल्टीपल आईपीस। मल्टीपल आईपी से लॉग
इन अटेम्प्ट्स हो रहे हैं। अकाउंट टेकओर्स
हो रहे हैं। इंपॉसिबल ट्रेवल अलर्ट्स आ
रहे हैं। ये सारी चीजें एसओसी अलर्ट्स में
जो है आपके एसओसी एलवन देखेंगे। इसका रूट
कॉज क्या है? सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट रूट कॉज है
वीक हैशिंग फंक्शन या एल्गोरिदम का यूज़
करना। तो ये चीजें आपको क्लियर होनी
चाहिए। ये चीजें आपको समझ में आनी चाहिए।
आई थिंक आपको समझ में आ रहा है। यहां तक
समझ में आया सभी को ताकि मैं आगे बढूं।
इसके बाद एक और कांसेप्ट है वो भी थोड़ा
समझेंगे। यहां तक अंडरस्टैंड
अंडरस्टैंडिंग है आपकी हो गई है। सभी
बताइए [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] प्लीज लेट
मी नो। गाइस आप लोग रिप्लाई फटाफट कीजिए
ताकि [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
पता चल सके। हाउ यू गेटिंग?
अंडरस्टुड
ओके
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
हम ओके ठीक है सो मोस्टली लोगों ने समझ
लिया इसको अच्छी बात है वेरी गुड
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब आते हैं
देखो आपको आपने अभी तक हैशिंग क्या होता
है समझ लिया आपने हैशिंग
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] की प्रॉपर्टीज
देख ली [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] हैश
एल्गोरिदम्स कॉमन है उसको देख लिया
पासवर्ड हैश क्यों करना चाहिए वो समझ ली
बिना सॉर्टिंग वाला प्रॉब्लम वो समझ लिया
सॉल्टिंग क्या होती है वो समझ लिया
सॉल्टिंग क्यों पावरफुल है वो समझ लिया
इंक्रिप्शन वर्सेस हैशिंग के बारे में
छोटा सा ले लिया एसओसी का पर्सपेक्टिव
आपने देख लिया ठीक है ये सारी चीजें आपने
देख ली अब आते हैं एक एडवांस कांसेप्ट पे
जिसको हम बोलते हैं पीपर या पेपर इसको हम
पीपर बोल लेंगे जैसे पेपर साल्ट होती है
ना पेपर साल्ट पेपर तो आपने अब यह भी
नॉर्मल डेली लाइफ में सुना होगा पेपर
साल्ट पेपर साल्ट का मतलब है मिर्च वाली
कोई एक चीज है मिर्च वाली चीज है ठीक है
या पेपर स्प्रे यू कैन से पेपर स्प्रे
बोलते हैं पेपर स्प्रे मिर्च की स्प्रे तो
यहां पे एक और कांसेप्ट है पेपर मतलब अगर
साल्ट से काम नहीं चल पा रहा है साल्ट से
भी ज्यादा सिक्योर कोई चीज चाहिए वो है
पेपर काली मिर्च बिल्कुल काली और तीखी
मिर्च पेपर इज इक्वल टू क्या होते हैं?
पेपर इज इक्वल टू सीक्रेट वैल्यू स्टर्ड
आउटसाइड डेटाबेस। अब मान लो सॉर्टिंग से
काम नहीं चल रहा है। ठीक है? मान लो लेट्स
सपोज। तो अब इंस्टेड ऑफ़ पासवर्ड प्लस
साल्ट इट बिकम्स पासवर्ड प्लस साल्ट प्लस
पेपर। और ये होती है एक सीक्रेट वैल्यू जो
डेटाबेस के बाहर स्टर्ड की जाती है।
डेटाबेस के बाहर। तो अगर मान लो डेटाबेस
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो भी जाता है किसी पॉइंट
पे। मान लो कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो जाता है तो
सॉल्टेड हैश मिल जाएंगे। साल्ट्स सॉल्टेड
हैश मिल जाएंगे। साल्ट्स मिल जाएंगे। बट
स्टिल ये पेपर नहीं मिलेगा क्योंकि ये
आपके डेटाबेस में स्टोर ही नहीं है। ये
आउटसाइड डेटाबेस में कहीं पे सर्वर पे
स्टोर कर दिया गया है। ये एक दिमाग लगाने
वाली चीज यहां पे आ चुकी है। तो ये बहुत
डेडली कॉम्बिनेशन एंड एक अच्छी सिक्योरिटी
होती है जब आप पासवर्ड के साथ साल्ट तो
यूज़ कर ही रहे हैं बट उसके साथ ही पेपर को
यूज़ कर लिया आपने। तो इवन इफ डेटाबेस
लीक्स आर देयर अटैकर डज नॉट नो द पेपर
एक्स्ट्रा लेयर ऑफ प्रोटेक्शन है ये है ना
कमाल की चीज पेपर मजा आया ना सिंपल तो कुछ
इस तरीके से होता है एक पासवर्ड्स होती है
उसमें सॉल्टिंग होती है देन हैशिंग होती
है देन पहले सॉल्टिंग होती है आपकी देन
हैशिंग होती है एंड देन उसको वेरीफाई किया
जाता है एंड इसमें ये कांसेप्ट पेपर का
आता है सॉल्ट के ऊपर अप्लाई करने के लिए
पेपर सॉल्ट के बाद आप इसको अप्लाई होगा जो
कहीं और सेव होती
राइट गॉट इट
चलिए [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब आ
जाते हैं व्हाट इज इंक्रिप्शन नाउ वी आर
कमिंग ऑन व्हाट इज इंक्रिप्शन तो मैं इसको
थोड़ा सा यहां से उठा के इधर कर देता हूं
क्योंकि ये प्रॉब्लम कर रहा था इससे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब हम समझेंगे व्हाट इज इंक्रिप्शन तो
हमने हैशिंग देख लिया सॉल्टिंग देख ली
पेपर देख लिया सब कुछ देख लिया अब हम
इंक्रिप्शन को भी देखेंगे ेंगे क्योंकि
बहुत लोग कंफ्यूज होते हैं हैशिंग और
इंक्रिप्शन को लेके। बहुत लोगों को लगता
है हैशिंग और इंक्रिप्शन सेम है। बहुत
लोगों को लगता है ऑलमोस्ट सिमिलर है। बट
ये शायद कई लोगों को नहीं पता होगी कि
दोनों में जमीन आसमान का अंतर है। ठीक है?
बहुत बड़ा डिफरेंस है। एंड अगर एक ईस्ट है
तो दूसरा वेस्ट है। ठीक है? दोनों में
बहुत अंतर है। दोनों का फंक्शनैलिटीज़ अलग
है। दोनों [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] का
काम अलग है। दोनों को अलग-अलग
अह अलग-अलग एरियाज में यूज़ किया जाता है।
ठीक है? पेपर अलग पेपर को फिर से समझा
दीजिए। देखो मैंने बहुत इजी लैंग्वेज में
समझाया है। वापस से मैंने इसलिए नहीं
बताता क्योंकि मैं चाहता हूं कि आप सेम
चीज को अगर आप वापस से समझना चाहते हैं तो
अगर आप रिकॉर्डिंग देखेंगे तो आपको वापस
समझ में आ जाएगा। सिंपल सा मतलब है जैसे
पासवर्ड के ऊपर साल्ट लगाया था तो एक और
एडिशनल लेयर ऑफ सिक्योरिटी है पासवर्ड
प्लस साल्ट प्लस पेपर। पेपर को भी लगा
दिया जाता है। जनरली पेपर को लगाने का
फायदा ये है कि पेपर जो वैल्यू है जैसे
साल्ट तो आपके डेटाबेस में स्टोर होती है।
पेपर की वैल्यू जो होती है सीक्रेट वैल्यू
होती है जो कि आउटसाइड डेटाबेस स्टोर किया
जाता है। तो अगर डेटाबेस हैक भी हो जाती
है तो पेपर नहीं मिलने वाला है। पासवर्ड
एंड साल्ट तो मिल जाएगा। हैश जो आपका है
वैल्यू मिल जाएगी साल्ट वाली। बट स्टिल
पेपर के बिना आप पासवर्ड क्रैकिंग वो नहीं
हो पाएगा। वो पासवर्ड क्रैक नहीं हो
पाएगी। तो कॉम्प्लेक्स बना देती है
पासवर्ड क्रैकिंग को और भी ज्यादा।
ठीक है।
हां मैं बहुत कंफ्यूजन में था। अब लग रहा
है क्लियर होगा। क्या बात है। बहुत अच्छी
बात है। आई आई एम वेरी हैप्पी।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब आते हैं इंक्रिप्शन क्या होती है? बहुत
बड़ी डिफरेंस है इंक्रिप्शन एंड हैशिंग
में। इस चीज को समझिएगा थोड़ा इजी वे में।
मैंने पहले ही बोला हैशिंग इंटीग्रिटी को
बचाती है। इंक्रिप्शन कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी को
बचाती है। ठीक है? हैशिंग हम किसी भी किसी
भी तरह के डेटा पे करते हैं। किसी भी तरह
के डेटा मेनली पासवर्ड्स मेनली पासवर्ड या
किसी भी तरह के डेटा पे। ठीक है?
इंक्रिप्शन में हम जब इंक्रिप्ट करते हैं
डेटा को तो हम उसको डिक्रिप्ट भी कर सकते
हैं। सिंपल सा। ठीक है? अब देखिए
इंक्रिप्शन इज द प्रोसेस ऑफ कन्वर्टिंग
रीडेबल डेटा यानी कि प्लेन टेक्स्ट इंटू
अनरीडेबल डेटा जिसको हम साइफर टेक्स्ट
बोलते हैं। यूजिंग अ क्रिप्टोग्राफिक की
सो दैट ओनली ऑथोराइज्ड पार्टीज कैन रीड
इट। एंड इसी से हमारी यहां पे
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी वाली बात आ जाती है।
कॉन्फिडेंसिटी
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी वाली चीज आ जाती है। तो
इंक्रिप्शन एक प्रोसेस है जहां पे रीडेबल
डेटा को यानी जिसको हम प्लेन टेक्स्ट
बोलते हैं। अनरीडेबल डेटा यानी साइफर
टेक्स्ट बोलते हैं। सफर का मतलब होता है
इंक्रिप्टेड यूजिंग अ क्रिप्टोग्राफी की।
क्रिप्टोग्राफी के की का यूज़ किया जाता
है। इसका इसलिए यूज़ इस तरीके ये प्रोसेस
लिए किया जाता है ताकि जो ऑथराइज्ड पार्टी
है सिर्फ वही डेटा को रीड कर पाए। अगर
मैंने आपके नाम से कोई संदेशा भेजा है तो
वो संदेशा सिर्फ आप ही तक पहुंचे। मतलब आप
ही उसको पढ़ें। यही इंक्रिप्शन होता है।
ठीक है? अब मान लो पहले के जमाने में
कबूतरों के थ्रू खत भेजा जाता था। यानी कि
लेटर भेजा जाता था। ठीक है? तो अब कबूतर
लेटर लेके जा रहा है। अब वो कबूतर जो है
वो लेटर किसी मान लो किसी रानी के लिए बनी
है। अब वो रानी की जगह वो किसी दासी को
लेटर दे दे रहा है। तो मैटर यहां पे तो
दिक्कत हो गई ना। गड़बड़ हो गई। तो यहां
पे इंक्रिप्शन सक्सेसफुल नहीं रहा। बस
सिर्फ रानी ही उस लेटर को पढ़ रही है।
रानी के पास डिलीवर हुआ है। तो वहां पे
इंक्रिप्शन फुलफिल हो जाती है। एंड दैट इज
कॉल्ड इंक्रिप्शन। ठीक है? अब उस लेटर के
अंदर जो भी चीजें लिखी गई हैं सिंपल सा
फंडा है। उसको पहुंचाना है जो ऑथराइज्ड
पर्सन है उस तक तो उस लिखी हुई चीज पे
इंक्रिप्शन अप्लाई किया जाता है एंड उस
लिखी हुई चीज को थोड़ा सा चेंज कर दिया
जाता है। एंड वही जो होती है इंक्रिप्शन
कहलाती है। तो होता क्या है यहां पे?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] बेसिक फ्लो क्या
है? प्लेन टेक्स्ट होता है। इंक्रिप्शन
एल्गोरिदम यूज़ किया जाता है। प्लस की एंड
देन साइफर टेक्स्ट यूज़ किया। सफर टेक्स्ट
यानी कि कनवर्टेड इंक्रिप्टेड टेक्स्ट आ
जाती है। देन साइफर टेक्स्ट को डिक्रिप्ट
कैसे करते हैं? जो इंक्रिप्टेड टेक्स्ट है
वो हो गया डिक्रिप्शन एल्गोरिदम यूज़ की
जाती है। यहां पे अब डिक्रिप्शन
डिक्रिप्शन एल्गोरिदम अप्लाई किया जा रहा
है। प्लस की का यूज़ किया जाता है और इसके
बाद प्लेन टेक्स्ट हमें मिल जाता है। सो
इंक्रिप्शन इज़ रिवर्सिबल इफ यू हैव द
करेक्ट की। करेक्ट की अगर है तो
इंक्रिप्शन जो है रिवर्सिबल है। तो पहले
के जमाने में कैसे किया जाता था वो भी मैं
बताता हूं आपको। मान लो ओरिजिनल मैसेज है
बैंक ट्रांसफर = 50,000 तो इंक्रिप्टेड
मैसेज क्या आएगा? कुछ इस तरीके से
इंक्रिप्ट करके मैसेज आएगी जो पढ़ना बहुत
मुश्किल हो जाएगा। विथ द करेक्ट की इट कैन
बी डिक्रिप्टेड बैक टू द ओरिजिनल मैसेज।
अगर आपके पास करेक्ट की है तो आप जो है
इसको डिक्रिप्ट कर सकते हैं। इसका सिंपल
सा एक तरीका सिंपल सा एक तरीका होता है।
देखो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एक लॉक है। लॉक
होती है। ठीक है? आप घर में लॉक लगाते हो
मेन गेट्स पे। जब कहीं बाहर जाते हो लॉक
लगा के जाते हो एक ताला मान लो ताला की
मैं बात कर रहा हूं ताले की तो उस लॉक को
आप एक ताले को आपने लॉक कर दिया गेट को अब
उस लॉक को आप कितने तरीके से मेनली खोल
सकते हो मुझे बताइए सोच के बताइएगा मैं एक
नॉर्मल सा क्वेश्चन पूछ रहा हूं आप एक लॉक
को देखो ऐसे तोड़ना नहीं है तोड़ के नहीं
खोलना है की से ही मतलब ऐसे
ऑथेंटिक वे में खोलना है ठीक है ना तो आप
कितने तरीके से मेनली खोल सकते हो उस लॉक
को बताइए मुझे।
हां। उस लॉक को कितने तरीके से खोल सकते
हैं? खोलनी तो आपको नॉर्मल ऑथेंटिक तरीके
से ही है। ऐसा नहीं कि लाके तोड़ देना है,
उसको कट कर देना है। ऐसा नहीं है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] हां, की से
खोल सकते हैं। बट उसमें भी उस की को की से
खोलने का कितना अप्रोच हो सकता है? किस
कितने तरीके की की के अप्रोचेस हो सकते
हैं आपके अकॉर्डिंग?
बताइए।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
डुप्लीकेट की बिल्कुल मास्टर की या
ओरिजिनल की डुप्लीकेट की बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
सही जवाब है अब यहां पे
ओनली व्हेन यू हैव द की बिल्कुल
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
चुराना होगा की एक बोल रहा है विंडो से
एंटर हो जाओ वाह
ओरिजिनल की डुप्लीकेट की। ठीक है? तो यहां
पे आप ने एक [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] लॉक
को बंद कर दिया। अब इस बात को गौर
कीजिएगा। इस बात पे ध्यान दीजिएगा। एक
ताला मार दिया आपने। अब उस ताले की चाबी
दो तरीके से आप डिस्ट्रीब्यूट कर सकते हो।
एक
एक [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सिंगल की है। एक सिंगल की है। एक सिंगल की
है। राइट? एंड उसी सिंगल की को आप यूज कर
रहे हो उस लॉक को ओपन करने के लिए।
लॉक को लगाने के लिए भी, लॉक को ओपन करने
के लिए भी। दूसरा तरीका यह हो सकता है कि
आपके पास एक
प्राइवेट की है और मल्टीपल पब्लिक कीज़ है।
मतलब क्या हुआ कि आपके पास एक प्राइवेट की
है। एक की है मास्टर की। प्राइवेट की है
और एक और मल्टीपल पब्लिक कीज़ है। मतलब
आपने पब्लिक के लिए जैसे चार लोगों को वह
एक्सेस देना है उस लॉक को खोलने का तो चार
अलग-अलग पब्लिक कीज़ भी हैं आपके पास। तो
आपने वो चार डिस्ट्रीब्यूट कर दिए। तो अब
वो लॉक या तो उस प्राइवेट की से खुल सकता
है या तो उन पब्लिक कीज़ से
डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड पब्लिक कीज़ से खुल सकता
है। ये एक अप्रोच हो सकती है। तो यही
अप्रोच जो यही अप्रोच है ये अप्रोच हम आगे
अभी समझने वाले हैं। आपको मैं आगे अभी
बताने वाला हूं। ठीक है? अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
आते हैं इंक्रिप्शन यूज़ में क्यों लिया
जाता है? व्हाई इंक्रिप्शन इज़ बीइंग
यूज्ड। इंक्रिप्शन प्रोटेक्ट डाटा
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी मीनिंग ओनली ऑथराइज
यूज़र्स कैन रीड द डाटा। यह मैंने पहले ही
बताया था। डाटा की कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी को
प्रोटेक्ट करता है इंक्रिप्शन। कॉमन यूज़
केसेस क्या है? एचटीटीपीएस वेबसाइट
ट्रैफिक इसमें इंक्रिप्शन होता है। वीpए
कम्युनिकेशन इंक्रिप्शन होता है। डिस्क
इंक्रिप्शन इंक्रिप्शन होता है। सिक्योर
मैसेजिंग में भी इंक्रिप्शन होता है। जैसे
आपने WhatsApp वगैरह पे देखा होगा। एंड टू
एंड इंक्रिप्शन बोलते हैं प्रोवाइड करते
हैं। फाइल इंक्रिप्शन, डेटाबेस
इंक्रिप्शन, ईमेल इंक्रिप्शन। तो यह सब
जगहों पे इंक्रिप्शन का यूज़ लिया जाता है
ताकि डाटा की कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी बनी रहे।
तो किस तरीके से यह काम करता है? प्लेन
टेक्स्ट होती है। इस पे अगर आपने
इंक्रिप्शन लगाया इंक्रिप्शन किस तरीके
से? सीक्रेट की के थ्रू यहां पे फिर
डिक्रिप्ट कर सकते हैं आप। और प्लेन
टेक्स्ट वापस आपको मिल जाएगी। तो आपने
प्लेन टेक्स्ट पे इंक्रिप्शन लगा के
इंक्रिप्ट कर दिया। इंक्रिप्टेड
डॉक्यूमेंट आपको यहां पे मिल जाती है। एंड
वहीं पे सिर्फ आपने जब सीक्रेट की का यूज़
किया तो इसको डिक्रिप्ट कर देंगे। एंड
वहां पे आपको फिर से प्लेन टेक्स्ट मिल
जाएगी। यानी सीक्रेट की यानी कि की इज द
की। की इज द की। की वेरीेंट ऑल
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] इट।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
की जो है बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। अब आते हैं
टाइप्स ऑफ इंक्रिप्शन। इं्रिप्शन के मेनली
मेनली दो टाइप्स होते हैं। एक सिमेट्रिक
और एक असिमेट्रिक।
एक होता है सिमेट्रिक और एक होता है
असिमेट्रिक जिसको कि पब्लिक की इंक्रिप्शन
भी बोलते हैं। तो हम पहले सॉरी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सॉरी पब्लिक की नहीं सिमेट्रिक इंक्रिप्शन
को देखेंगे।
सो वी विल फर्स्ट सीमेट्रिक
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
इंक्रिप्शन क्या होता है? देखो सिमेट्रिक
इंक्रिप्शन में ओनली सिंगल की जो है यूज़
में ली जाती है। ताले को लॉक भी करने के
लिए अनलॉक भी करने के लिए। इंक्रिप्ट करने
के लिए भी और डिक्रिप्ट करने के लिए भी।
दोनों के लिए सिमिलर की का यूज़ में किया
लिया जाता है। यानी एक सिंगल की का यूज़
किया जाता है। ठीक है? ये होते हैं
सिमेट्रिक इंक्रिप्शन। एग्जांपल प्लेन
टेक्स्ट प्लस सीक्रेट की तो साइफर
टेक्स्ट। साइफर टेक्स्ट प्लस सीक्रेट की
प्लेन टेक्स्ट। सिंपल ये होता है। प्लेन
टेक्स्ट में सीक्रेट की मतलब एक सिंगल की
होगी। तो ये कन्वर्ट हो जाएगी।
इंक्रिप्टेड हो जाएगी। और फिर उसी
इंक्रिप्टेड को उसी सीक्रेट की से उसी
सिंगल की से डिक्रिप्ट भी करके प्लेन
टेक्स्ट में वापस से हमें डेटा मिल जाएगी।
यूजज़ कैसे कहां पे होते हैं? डिस्कस के
इंक्रिप्शन जो होते हैं या वीपीए टनल्स या
वीपीए इंक्रिप्शन जो होते हैं या फाइल
इंक्रिप्शनंस जो होते हैं वो जनरली
सिमेट्रिक इंक्रिप्शन पे काम करते हैं।
सिंगल की होती है इंक्रिप्शन के लिए और
डिक्रिप्शन के लिए दोनों के लिए। ठीक है?
प्रॉब्लम क्या है यहां पे? कि की शेयरिंग
मस्ट बी सिक्योर। अब क्योंकि सिंगल की है
इंक्रिप्शन के लिए भी और डिक्रिप्शन के
लिए भी। तो जो कीज़ है उसकी शेयरिंग वो
बहुत ही ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट हो जाती है एंड
सिक्योरली उसको शेयर करना चाहिए। मतलब जो
एक्चुअल बंदा है सामने जिसको वो डाटा
चाहिए उसी के साथ शेयर करना चाहिए।
अदरवाइज कोई भी आपके घर के अंदर लॉक को
खोल के घुस जाएगा। क्योंकि चाबी एक ही है।
उसी से लॉक बंद हुई थी। उसी से लॉक वापस
से आपकी खुल जाएगी। यह सिमेट्रिक। अब इस
सिमेट्रिक
इंक्रिप्शन के अंदर में
बहुत सारे अलग-अलग एल्गोरिदम है। जैसे हैश
एल्गोरिद्स थे ना हैशिंग एल्गोरिदम। उसी
तरीके से यहां पे सिमिट्रिक इंक्रिप्शन
एल्गोरिद्स अलग-अलग हैं। जिसमें से कुछ
पॉपुलर एल्गोरिद्स मैं आपको बता रहा हूं।
जिसमें कि एक एईएस आपका है, डीईएस है, 3Ds
है, चार चार 20 ये सारे अलग-अलग
एल्गोरिदम्स हैं। अब मैं आपको यहां पे नाम
तो बता रहा हूं पॉपुलर एल्गोरिदम्स के।
आपका टास्क अगेन आपको समझ में आ गया होगा।
हर क्लास में सेम टास्क से सिमिलर तरीके
से टास्क रहेंगे। जब भी मैं कोई कांसेप्ट
पे कोई पॉइंट्स बता रहा हूं तो मैं एसओसी
लेवल वन के अकॉर्डिंग बता रहा हूं। उसके
रिक्वायरमेंट के अकॉर्डिंग बता रहा हूं।
बट आपसे रिक्वेस्ट ये है कि एज अ टास्क आप
उसको एक्सप्लोर करें। एईएस के बारे में
थोड़ा नॉलेज लें। डीईएस अलग-अलग इन
इंक्रिप्शन एल्गोरििदम्स के बारे में
थोड़ी पढ़ें। उसके नोट्स बनाएं। पॉइंट्स
को नोट करें। Lindin पे पोस्ट कीजिए और
हमें टाइप कीजिए डिफरनिश को। ठीक है?
चाचा हां चाचा 20 चाचा 20 ठीक है
[हंसी]
ठीक है चाचा 20 अब एईएस क्या है इसका यूज़
क्या है मोस्ट कॉमन मॉडर्न इंक्रिप्शन है
जो सबसे ज्यादा यूज़ में ली जाती है एईएस
जो आपका इंक्रिप्शन है आपके आपने शायद
देखा होगा Windows का भी अगर पासवर्ड की
मैं बात करूं तो उसमें भी शायद एईएस यूज़
में आता है। मैं आपको यहां पे दिखाने की
कोशिश करता हूं। इफ आई कैन गेट मुझे मिल
जाता है अगर मैं कंट्रोल पैनल में
Windows सो देयर वाज़ देयर वि नेटवर्क
शेयरिंग सेंटर पे चलते हैं हम यहां चलते
हैं वायरलेस प्रॉपर्टीज पे चलते हैं एंड
सिक्योरिटी पे चलते हैं। यहां पे आप देख
सकते हैं कि यहां पे सिक्योरिटी में यहां
पे जो आपकी Windows के अंदर में वायरलेस
सिक्योरिटी जो जो है आपकी वायरलेस
सिक्योरिटी तो इस वायरलेस सिक्योरिटी के
अंदर में जो इंक्रिप्शन टाइप यूज़ हो रहा
है दैट इज़ एईएस
ये आपका एईएस इंक्रिप्शन टाइप है। ये आप
देख सकते हैं यहां पे एईएस यूज़ हो रहा है।
सो, ए जो है वन ऑफ़ द मोस्ट सिक्योर एंड वन
ऑफ़ द मोस्ट अह अह डिमांडेड या वन ऑफ़ द
मोस्ट यूज़्ड इंक्रिप्शन टेक्निक्स हैं जो
कि मॉडर्न इंक्रिप्शन अह जो गोल्स हैं
उनको फुलफिल करती है मॉडर्न डे में इसका
यूज़ किया जाता है इंक्रिप्शन के लिए। ठीक
है? हां जी। हां जी। इसका फुल फॉर्म है
एडवांस इंक्रिप्शन स्टैंडर्ड। यह फुल
फॉर्म वगैरह आप लोग देखते रहिएगा। तभी
मैंने बोला एक्सप्लोर कीजिएगा थोड़ा। आपको
फुल फॉर्म भी क्लियर हो जाएगा।
देन डीएस जो है वह ओल्ड होता है एंड
इनसिक्योर है। जनरली यूज में जनरली नहीं
ली जाती है। 3DS एक लेगसी एल्गोरिदम है।
बहुत पुराने सिस्टम्स में यह यूज़ किया
जाता था। चारचा 20 मॉडर्न सिक्योर
इंक्रिप्शन है। तो चारचा 20 कुछ ज्यादा
मतलब एकदम मॉडर्न इंक्रिप सिक्योर
इंक्रिप्शन है। अभी फिलहाल के लिए मॉडर्न
में भी एईएस को मोस्टली यूज़ किया जाता है।
तो यह एल्गोरििदम्स हैं इंक्रिप्शन के।
ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब यहां पर
आते हैं असिमेट्रिक इंक्रिप्शन जिसको कि
हम पब्लिक की क्रिप्टोग्राफी भी कहते हैं।
पब्लिक की क्रिप्टोग्राफी। ठीक है?
असिमेट्रिक पहले हमने सिमेट्रिक देखा। अब
असिमेट्रिक इंक्रिप्शन देख रहे हैं। अब
असिमेट्रिक इंक्रिप्शन में डिफरेंट चीज
होती है। उसमें एक ही की था जिससे
इंक्रिप्ट भी कर रहे थे, डिक्रिप्ट भी कर
रहे थे। सिमेट्रिक में। असिमेट्रिक में
क्या होते हैं? दो कीज़ का यूज़ लिया जाता
है। एक पब्लिक की होती है और एक प्राइवेट
की होती है। तो पब्लिक की सबके साथ शेयर
किया जाता है। पब्लिक की इज बीइंग शेयरर्ड
विद एवरीबॉडी। बट जो प्राइवेट की है उसको
सीक्रेट रखा जाता है। प्राइवेट की आपका
मास्टर की है जो आपके पास होगा और पब्लिक
की सबको बांट दिया जाता है।
सबको बांट दो। तो प्रोसेस क्या है? पब्लिक
की से इंक्रिप्ट करना और प्राइवेट की से
डिक्रिप्ट करना। यह प्रोसेस है कि पब्लिक
की जो बांटी है आपने उससे इंक्रिप्ट तो
होगा बट डिक्रिप्ट ऑलवेज ऑलवेज प्राइवेट
की से होगा। डिक्रिप्शन ऑलवेज किससे होगी?
प्राइवेट की से होगी। ये एक इसका टेक्निक
होता है कि भैया इंक्रिप्ट तो कर दो सब।
जिसके पास पब्लिक है सब मारो इंक्रिप्शन।
सब मारो सब इंक्रिप्ट कर सकते हैं। बट
प्राइवेट की डिक्रिप्शन के लिए होता है।
जैसे आपको मैं अब एग्जांपल के तौर पे
बताता हूं। जस्ट फॉर एग्जांपल आपने
WhatsApp में WhatsApp में देखा होगा। अगर
आप देखेंगे WhatsApp पे मैं आपको अभी बता
देता हूं।
WhatsApp में जब आप सेटिंग्स में अपने
जाएंगे यू विल गो टू द सेटिंग्स एंड उसके
बाद आप जाएंगे अ
जस्ट अ सेकंड।
हम हम हम
बिल्कुल
अब WhatsApp में जब आप सेटिंग्स में
जाएंगे और अकाउंट्स ऑप्शन पे जाएंगे
WhatsApp पे तो सबसे ऊपर में एक
सिक्योरिटी नोटिफिकेशन ऑप्शन मिलेगा। उस
पे आप जाइएगा। उसमें जब आप जाएंगे तो यहां
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] पे एक चीज लिखी
होती है।
एक चीज लिखी होती है। योर चैट्स एंड कॉल्स
आर प्राइवेट। एंड टू एंड इंक्रिप्शंस
कीप्स योर पर्सनल मैसेजेस एंड कॉल्स
बिटवीन यू एंड द पीपल यू चूज़। ठीक है? नो
वन आउटसाइड द चैट नॉट इवन WhatsApp कैन
रीड, लिसन टू और शेयर देम। दिस इंक्लूड्स
योर टेक्स्ट एंड वॉइस मैसेजेस, ऑडियो एंड
वीडियो कॉल्स, फोटोस, वीडियोस,
डॉक्यूमेंट्स, लोकेशन शेयरिंग, स्टेटस
अपडेट्स एक्सट्रा एक्सट्रा। अब यहां पे आई
डोंट नो कि ये कितना वैलिड है। यह यहां पे
लिखा हुआ। एंड आप सबको पता होगा कि यह
कितना वैलिड है, कितना वैलिड हो सकता है
कि WhatsApp यह लिखना कि WhatsApp भी
एक्सेस नहीं कर सकता है। फलाना ढगाना जो
भी है व्हाटएवर।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
तो यहां पे आपके होता क्या है कि WhatsApp
सारे यूज़र्स को पब्लिक की दे चुकी है।
पब्लिक की से सारे इंक्रिप्शनंस हो रहे
हैं। जो भी कम्युनिकेशन है, जो भी चीजें
हैं वो इंक्रिप्ट हो रही है। बट प्राइवेट
की जो है
वो सीक्रेट है। एंड सिर्फ उसी से
डिक्रिप्ट हो सकती है वो इंक्रिप्टेड
टेक्स्ट। यह एक बेनिफिट है असिमेट्रिक
इंक्रिप्शन का। एंड ये एक मोर सिक्योर
अपॉर्चुनिटी मोर सिक्योर अप्रोच है
किसी भी तरह के फिलिंग टेक्स्ट को साइफर
टेक्स्ट या इंक्रिप्टेड टेक्स्ट में
कन्वर्ट करने का
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
आर यू गेटिंग गाइस
आर यू गेटिंग
यस एसिमिट्री का मतलब मतलब होता है टू कीज़
रिक्वायर्ड। वन इज़ पब्लिक एंड वन इज़
प्राइवेट।
असिमेट्रिक [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
में दो कीज़ की रिक्वायरमेंट है। एक पब्लिक
की और एक प्राइवेट की। तो पब्लिक की
जो सबके पास शेयर्ड है। प्राइवेट की जो है
जो आपकी सीक्रेट है जिससे कि डेटा को
डिक्रिप्ट
किया जाता है। डेटा को डिक्रिप्ट आप कर
सकते हैं। आपकी अपनी इंक्रिप्टेड डेटा है
तो आपने पब्लिक की से इंक्रिप्ट करा करा
हुआ। आप पब्लिक की से वो इंक्रिप्ट हो
चुकी है। एंड आपके अपनी प्राइवेट एक
मास्टर की है जिससे कि आप उसको डिक्रिप्ट
कर सकते हो। कोई और उसको डिक्रिप्ट नहीं
कर सकता है। दिस इज़ व्हाट अ सिमेट्रिक
इंक्रिप्शन टेल्स अस।
अब तो क्लियर हो गया होगा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
गॉट इट? बस तो यही है सिंपल कि दोनों
चीजें होती है पब्लिक की प्राइवेट की और
उसमें क्या होता है? सिमेट्रिक में सिर्फ
एक सिंगल की होती है। एग्जांपल यूसेस क्या
एचटीपीएस वेबसाइट्स, एसएसएल, टीएलएस
हैंडशक, ईमेल इंक्रिप्शन
ये सारी चीज़ होती है। ये आपका
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एग्जांपल में या
किसी सोशल मीडिया कम्युनिकेशन हो गई जैसे
WhatsApp कम्युनिकेशन ये सब एग्जांपल। अब
इसमें पॉपुलर एल्गोरििदम्स कौन-कौन से
होते हैं? एक आपका आरएसए होता है। एक आप
ईसीसी है, डेफी हेलमैन है। तो आरएसए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
जो है वो एसएसएल एंड टीएलएस वगैरह जो होती
है स्ट सिक्योर सिक्योर सॉकेट लेयर या
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर सिक्योरिटी इसमें यूज़
किया जाता है। ईसीसी जो है मॉडर्न सिक्योर
कम्युनिकेशन में यूज़ किया जाता है। ये जो
एल्गोरिदम्स है डेफी हेलमेन जो है की
एक्सचेंज के टाइम की एक्सचेंज प्रोसेस में
यूज़ किया जाता है। डेफी हेलमेन नाम का
इंक्रिप्शन एल्गोरिदम। तो ये एल्गोरिदम्स
हैं। आपसे रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं। हां यहां
पे किसी ने अह इसके फुल फॉर्म लिख दिए हैं
अह रिवर्स समीर एडलमैन क्योंकि यह उनके
फाउंडर के उस पे ये नाम आरएसए है इलिप्टिक
कर्व क्रिप्टोग्राफी ईसीसी हो गई एंड डेफी
हेलमेन हो गई तो अच्छी बात है जितने लोगों
ने इसको फिर इज़ अ टास्क क्या है कि आप इन
पॉपुलर एल्गोरिदम या और भी एल्गोरिदम्स को
थोड़ा एक्सप्लोर करेंगे खुद से भी जानेंगे
उसके बारे में डिटेल थोड़ा
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सा समझेंगे।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है? अब यहां पे आते हैं एचटीपीएस का
एग्जांपल लेते हैं। इंक्रिप्शन के अह अह
इंक्रिप्शन के उसमें इंक्रिप्शन के अंदर
एचटीटीपीएस का एग्जांपल लेके हम देखते हैं
कि कैसे ये काम करता है। जब भी आप एक
वेबसाइट विजिट करते हैं यानी ब्राउज़र से
सर्वर को एक्सेस करने की कोशिश करते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अभी किसी ने पूछा था कैसे स्टोर होती है।
कहां पे होती है? ये कीज़ कहां पे होते
हैं? उसी का आंसर है। मैं आपको पहले ही
बोल चुका हूं। आप जो भी क्वेश्चन पूछेंगे
उसका आंसर मेरे पास ऑलरेडी मैं जो है आपके
लिए लेकर आता हूं ऑलरेडी। तो आप थोड़ा सा
वेट कीजिए आपको आंसर मिलेगा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ब्राउज़र [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] गेट्स
पब्लिक की फ्रॉम सर्वर। ब्राउज़र सबसे
पहले सर्वर से पब्लिक की लेता है। ठीक है?
ब्राउज़र इंक्रिप्ट्स सेशन की। अब सेशन की
जो कि बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट रोल प्ले करता है।
उसको इंक्रिप्ट करता है उस यूजर के। सर्वर
डिक्रिप्ट्स यूजिंग प्राइवेट की। अब सर्वर
ने पब्लिक की तो दे दिया यूजर को बट
प्राइवेट की उसके पास है तो उस प्राइवेट
की से उसको डिक्रिप्ट करता है। सिक्योर
कम्युनिकेशन बिगिंस एंड यहां पे सिक्योर
कम्युनिकेशन स्टार्ट हो जाती है। इसी
तरीके से एचटीटीपीएस वर्क करता है।
एचटीटीपी के केस में ये चीजें नहीं होती
हैं। इसलिए वो अनसिक्योर ट्रांसमिशन होता
है। जहां प्लेन टेक्स्ट में आपके डेटा
जाती है, ट्रेवल करती हैं एचटीटीp में। बट
एचटीटीपीएस में यहां पे क्या होता है? है
पब्लिक की सर्वर से लेके ब्राउज़र
इंक्रिप्ट करता है सेशन की को और सर्वर
फिर उसको डिक्रिप्ट करता है एंड
कम्युनिकेशन स्टार्ट हो जाती है। कुछ इस
तरीके से यहां पे मैं एलिस और बॉब की बात
कर रहा हूं। तो ये प्लेन टेक्स्ट में एलिस
जो है इंक्रिप्शन का पब्लिक की के थ्रू
इंक्रिप्शन करते हैं। यहां पे इंक्रिप्टेड
डेटा होता है। एंड यहां पे जो बॉब है जो
बेसिकली सर्वर यू कैन से वो रिसिपिएंट्स
की जो प्राइवेट की है अपनी उससे डिक्रिप्ट
कर देता है उस डेटा को। एंड इस तरीके से
यह पब्लिक इंक्रिप्शन की ये वर्कशॉप
कंप्लीट होती है। यह हो गया एचटीडीपीएस का
एग्जांपल। एचटीडीपीएस एग्जांपल समझ में आ
गया गाइज़ आपको? एवरीवन अंडरस्टुड?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? समझ में आ गया होगा। मेरे ख्याल
से आना भी चाहिए क्योंकि बहुत इजी वे में
मैं समझाने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं। आर यू
गेटिंग गाइस? आर यू गेटिंग गाइस? आर यू
गेटिंग गाइस?
ठीक है। कोई बात नहीं।
अब यहां [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] पर
इंक्रिप्शन वर्सेस हैशिंग का मैं फिर से
कंपैरिजन करता हूं थोड़ा डिटेल में। तो
रिवर्सिबल कौन सा है? इंक्रिप्शन
रिवर्सिबल है। हैशिंग रिवर्सिबल नहीं है।
यू की का यूज़ कौन करता है? इंक्रिप्शन
करता है। हैशिंग की का यूज़ नहीं करता है।
पर्पस क्या है? डेटा की कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी
को मेंटेन करना। हैशिंग में इंटीग्रिटी
मेंटेन होती है। इसको सेफगार्ड करना।
आउटपुट लेंथ वेरिएबल होती है। इंक्रिप्शन
में कुछ भी लेंथ हो सकता है। हैशिंग में
फिक्स्ड लेंथ होती है। एग्जांपल एचtपीएस
की ट्रैफिक या WhatsApp कम्युनिकेशन ये
इंक्रिप्शन के एग्जांपल्स हैं। पासवर्ड की
स्टोरेज या पासवर्ड की जो अ पासवर्ड की
हैशिंग ये जो है आपका इसका एग्जांपल है
का। कैन ओरिजिनल डाटा बी रिट्रीव्ड? सो
इंक्रिप्शन में ओरिजिनल डेटा को रिट्रीव
किया जा सकता है। बट हैशिंग में ओरिजिनल
डेटा को रिट्रीव नहीं किया जा सकता है। सो
दिस इज़ द मेन कंपैरिजन। दिस इज़ द मेन
डिफरेंस बिटवीन हैशिंग एंड इंक्रिप्शन। अब
यहां पे एसओसी एनालिस्ट का पर्सपेक्टिव
क्या हो सकता है? अगर आप एक एसओसी
एनालिस्ट एल1 हैं तो आपका पर्सपेक्टिव
क्या हो सकता है? अंडरस्टैंडिंग दिस
हेल्प्स इन आपको इन टॉपिक्स के बारे में
अंडरस्टैंडिंग होना आपकी किस चीज़ में
हेल्प करेगी? इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग डाटा
ब्रचेस। डाटा ब्रचेस में आप हेल्प आपको
बहुत ज्यादा हेल्प करने वाली है। पासवर्ड
डम्स को एनालाइज करने में आपको हेल्प करने
वाली है। डेट क्रेडेंशियल्स थप्ट को
अंडरस्टैंड करने में एंड उसको एक्सप्लोर
करने में आपको हेल्प करने वाली है।
इंक्रिप्टेड ट्रैफिक को इन्वेस्टिगेट जब
आप करेंगे उसमें आपको ये कांसेप्ट्स हेल्प
करेंगी। एंड मैलवेयर एनालिसिस में भी ये
कांसेप्ट्स आपकी हेल्प करेंगी। एसओसी का
एग्जांपल क्वेश्चन मैं यहां पे आपको दे
रहा हूं। तो इफ अटैकर स्टील इफ
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अटैकर स्टील
इंक्रिप्टेड [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
डेटाबेस तो हार्डर टू एक्सेस हैश
पासवर्ड्स तो मे क्रैक ऑफलाइन ठीक है
सिंपल सा फंडा है तो ये एक क्वेश्चन आप
एसओसी के लिए मैंने यहां पे डाला हुआ है
कि इफ अटैकर स्टील इंक्रिप्टेड डेटाबेस
अगर है तो हार्ड होगा एक्सेस करने के लिए
ऑब्वियस सी बात है एंड अगर हैश पासवर्ड
होगा तो विदाउट सॉल्ट है तो मे बी क्रैग्ड
बट अगर सॉल्टेड है तो इट्स क्वाइट अ
डिफिकल्ट एंड अगर सॉल्टेड हैश जो सॉल्टेड
के साथ पेपर भी आपने उसमें ऐड किया है तो
दैट इज़ मोर सिक्योर मोर कॉम्प्लेक्स टू
क्रैक तो ये एसओसी का एक पर्सपेक्टिव होता
है। ठीक है? दैट्स
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] दैट्स
द एंड ऑफ़ दिस सेशन। दैट्स द एंड ऑफ़ दिस
टॉपिक्स जो मेरे को आज आपको कराने थे।
क्योंकि मैं जो भी इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक्स हैं
बिफोर स्टार्टिंग द एक्चुअल एसआईएम एंड
प्रैक्टिकल थिंग्स वो जिसके बिना इन
कांसेप्ट्स और टॉपिक्स के बिना आप अधूरे
हैं आपको कुछ नहीं समझ में आएगा आगे चलके
वो मैंने यहां पे एक उसमें से एक और टॉपिक
कंप्लीट करा है यहां पे। आगे क्लासेस में
और भी टॉपिक्स हैं जो उनको कंप्लीट मैं
करूंगा। देन हम प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट पे आएंगे
तो आपको सारी चीजें समझ में आएंगी और आपको
मजा भी आएगा। ठीक है? यू विल यू विल बी
डिलाइटेड। आपको बहुत मजा आएगा क्योंकि
आपको सब समझ में आएंगी ना चीज़ तो आपको मजा
आना शुरू हो जाएगा। बट नहीं अगर समझ में
आएंगी तो आपको बहुत गुस्सा आएगा। आपको
लगेगा अरे यार क्या हो रहा है? क्या समझ
में आ रहा है? तो प्लीज़ आप इस चीज़ को
समझिए। क्योंकि एसओसी बनने के लिए आपको
साइबर सिक्योरिटी के भी कुछ कांसेप्ट्स को
ध्यान में रखने हैं। नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी
नेटवर्किंग का भी कुछ कांसेप्ट्स हैं।
उसको भी ध्यान में रखना है। डिजिटल
फॉरेंसिक्स के भी कुछ कांसेप्ट्स होंगे।
उनको भी ध्यान में रखना है। एंड देन आपका
एसओसी वाला पार्ट एसआईएम एंड अलग-अलग तरह
के सेमुलेशन एंड ये सब हम देखेंगे। अटैक्स
वगैरह को देखेंगे। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके। यहां पे प्लीज प्लीज आप
शुभम इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट नॉट टू स्पैम
क्योंकि फिर टाइम आउट करना पड़ेगा। सभी के
लिए सेम रूल है। सो प्लीज इट्स अ
रिक्वेस्ट। ओके? सो सभी को समझ में आ गया
है? मुझे बता दीजिए एक बार। एवरीवन
अंडरस्टुड टुडे सेशन?
सर जो डाटा सेंड करते हैं वो अपने पब्लिक
की से इंक्रिप्ट करते हैं या जिसे भेजते
हैं उसे पब्लिक की। मैंने आपको अभी बताया।
अभी जस्ट मैंने आपको बताया। आपने यहां पे
शायद ध्यान नहीं दिया होगा लास्ट जो यहां
पे स्लाइड है यहां पे कि ब्राउज़र गेट्स
पब्लिक की फ्रॉम सर्वर जब कम्युनिकेशन
स्टार्ट होती है क्लाइंट सर्वर की बात
होती है तो ब्राउज़र गेट्स पब्लिक की फ्रॉम
सर्वर
अब समझ में आ गया शुभम आपको यहां पे अब
क्लियर हुआ ब्राउज़र इंक्रिप्ट्स द सेशन की
तो इंक्रिप्ट किसके से इंक्रिप्ट करता है
सेशन की को किसके पब्लिक की से कहां से
उसने लिया है पब्लिक सर्वर से लिया है।
दैट्स व्हाट योर क्वेश्चन इज़ आंसर्ड। तो
आई थिंक अब समझ में आ गया होगा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
समझ में आ गया शुभम आपको?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है। बढ़िया बात है। अच्छी बात है।
अंडरस्टुड। ओके।
बहुत अच्छी। सर नेक्स्ट क्लास इंडिया
चैंपियन होने के अगले दिन मंडे। हां। यस
गाइस। अ सो ऑब्वियस सी बात है टुडे इज
फ्राइडे। तो कल तो सेशन नहीं होगी। सैटरडे
को नहीं होगी। संडे को मैंने सोचा था सेशन
लेने की। बट संडे को सेशन इसलिए नहीं होगी
क्योंकि संडे को T20 वर्ल्ड कप का फाइनल
है जिसमें इंडिया खेलेगी इंडीज सॉरी
एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी न्यूजीलैंड के साथ। एंड
उस समय सेशन रखना ही गलत गलती होगी बहुत
बड़ी। तो सेशन हम नहीं रखेंगे। तो मोस्ट
प्रोबेबबली आपके कमेंट्स के ऊपर डिपेंड
करता है। अगर आपने कमेंट्स पूरे कर दिए
संडे तक 200 प्लस कमेंट्स इंडिविजुअल
यूनिक कमेंट्स तो मंडे को आपकी क्लास हो
जाएगी। नहीं तो फिर ट्यूसडे को होगी वो
आपके ऊपर डिपेंड करता है। राइट?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
दैट्स टोटली अप टू यू। ओके। ओके। अब यहां
पे टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट देख लेते हैं। अगेन
फर्स्ट नंबर पे है पीतांबर। देन है सेकंड
मिस्टर रोबोट नमन जगतगुरु अमित यादव
आदित्य प्रशांत आदित्य अल्टीमेट गेमिंग
जेडी कोडर साइबर नक्स ये बॉय विदु
विद विदु शेखर गेमिंग गेमिंग किलर शुभम यस
गडकर हसनबर्ग ऋषु सिक्योर हं मिस्टर जट
टॉप रेड टीम सेलर आदि की आर्ट रितिक सागर
अह रिक्वेद पॉल जो भी है आपका नाम सॉरी
रिया कंचन रैंडम बॉय आकाश प्रवीण गौरव टेक
गाय रोहित संदीप डीआरजी उस्मान अली रवि
राठौर प्रदीप कुमार शरीफ खत शरीफ सफ ओके
सुहेल अशोक
सोसे आदित्य अनिकेत तनवीर हंटर एक्स
श्रीपद
श्रीपदा
सलोनी राय
क्रिएटिव बाइट एंड सुजोए शाह। ओके। सो
ग्रेट एंड थैंक यू वेरी मच। टॉप फैंस की
लिस्ट में आपका नाम आया है। आप सभी लोग
टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट में है। एंड
आई थिंक इट्स ग्रेट टू सी यू गाइस हियर।
मुझे भी काफी मजा आता है जब मैं आपको ऐसे
लिस्ट में यहां पे देखता हूं। एंड इट्स
फील सो ग्रेट। एंड आई होप कि आप ऐसे ही
कंटिन्यू करेंगे। कंटिन्यू आप ऐसे ही
अटेंड करते रहेंगे लाइव सेशंस को एंड
कांसेप्ट्स को सीखते रहेंगे। तो अब आपका
काम है इस सेशन के बाद आपका वो काम क्या
है कि नाउ अ रिकॉर्डिंग को वापस से देखिए।
इस इस क्लास के कमेंट्स में जाइए। वहां पे
अपना फुल नेम डालिए। एंड लिखिए कि यू
कंप्लीटेड दिस पर्टिकुलर क्लास। एंड 200
प्लस कमेंट्स होते ही नेक्स्ट क्लास आपकी
आ जाएगी। एंड जितने भी की पॉइंट्स आप
लिखेंगे एंड जो भी आप टॉपिक्स को
एक्सप्लोर करेंगे उसके बारे में जो भी
जानेंगे की पॉइंट्स बनाएंगे उसको Lindin
पे डालेंगे आप और टैग करेंगे डेफ्रोनिक्स
को एंड मुझे भी आप टैग कर सकते हैं एंड
देन वी विल बी सीइंग दोज़ टॉपिक्स दोज़ की
पॉइंट्स। तो अब मैं सब चीज़ देखता हूं
Lindin पे भी मैं सारी पोस्ट्स देखता हूं।
हर एक बंदे की। हो सकता है मैं सबके लाइक
ना करता हूं। बट मैं देखता सबके हूं। एंड
मैं वैसे लोगों की जो रेगुलर डाल रहे हैं
उसकी लिस्ट भी बना रहा हूं। मेरे पास
लिस्ट भी आ चुकी है। ऐसे 10 बंदों की
लिस्ट अभी भी है मेरे पास जो बहुत रेगुलर
डालते रहते हैं, पोस्ट करते रहते हैं। एंड
दे विल गेट मोर अ बिट ऑफ़ मोर बेनिफिट देन
द अदर पीपल। मैं बताऊंगा बहुत कुछ
सरप्राइज इस पूरे ट्रेनिंग में बहुत कुछ
अभी आपको समझने और जानने को मिलेगा। बहुत
कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें भी सरप्राइजज़ मिलते
रहेंगे। तो बने रहिए साथ में। नेक्स्ट
क्लास में हम बहुत जल्द मिलेंगे।
डीसीएपीटी का नेक्स्ट बैच जून जुलाई में
लगभग शुरू हो जानी चाहिए एंड आपको इनफॉर्म
कर दिया जाएगा। राइट
बीकॉम [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
किया है तो चांसेस आर लेस क्योंकि अगर
डिग्री खोज देगा कोई कॉल कोई कोई कंपनी
डिग्री के लिए डिमांड करेगा आप बीकॉम कर
रहे हैं बीए कर रहे हैं आपने कुछ भी करा
हो अगर आपने टेक्निकल डिग्री नहीं करी है
और कोई कंपनी टेक्निकल डिग्री मांग देती
है तो उस केस में अगर उनका एकदम वो फर्म
है कि नहीं टेक्निकल डिग्री के बिना नहीं
लेंगे तो आप कुछ नहीं कर सकते उसमें तो
आपको एक टेक्निकल डिग्री लेनी पड़ेगी बट
अगर कोई फर्म है जो थोड़ी लिबरल है चलेगा
काम आपके इंटरव्यू एंड आपकी स्किल्स पे
फोकस करके वो आपको जॉब दे रहे हैं तो ऐसे
भी कम कंपनीज़ हैं। ऐसी कंपनीज़ के लिए आप
अप्रोच कर सकते हैं। राइट?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ठीक है?
ओके गाइस। सो, थैंक यू वेरी मच फॉर
जॉइनिंग द सेशन। फॉर जॉइनिंग दिस सेशन। आई
होप यू एंजॉयड द सेशन। अगर आपको अच्छा लगा
है सेशन। आपने कुछ सीखा है तो एक ही चीज
बोलूंगा। जाते-जाते लाइक ठोकते जाइएगा
सेशन पे। सेशन को शेयर कीजिएगा अपने
दोस्तों के बीच। जितने भी आपके कॉलीग्स
हैं जो एसओसी एल1 के लिए एक पेड क्लास जॉइ
करने वाले थे या पेड कोर्स लेने वाले थे
या पेड ट्रेनिंग करने वाले थे उनको बताइए
कि ये एक पेड ट्रेनिंग ही है फ्री में मिल
रही है दैट्स इट उसी लेवल की कंटेंट उसी
लेवल का क्वालिटी एंड एक जॉब रेडी
ट्रेनिंग मैं बोल रहा हूं तो इसमें कुछ ना
कुछ तो बात होगी तो उनको बताइए उनके साथ
शेयर कीजिए अपने Telegram WhatsApp
Facebook ग्रुप्स में सब जगह फैलाइए ताकि
मैक्सिमम लोग इस तक पहुंचे मेरी बस यही
रिक्वेस्ट है और हमारी हेल्प आपके थ्रू बस
ये आप कर दोगे यही बहुत है। ठीक है? एंड
कमेंट्स करना मत भूलिएगा। ग्रुप्स को जॉइ
कर लीजिएगा वो एसओसी वाले एंड सोशल मीडिया
पे हमसे कनेक्ट हो जाइएगा। सो बस अगर आपने
सब्सक्राइब नहीं करा होगा डेफ्रोनिस्ट को
तो प्लीज सब्सक्राइब जरूर कीजिएगा और बेल
आइकॉन ऑल नोटिफिकेशन टर्न ऑन कर दीजिएगा।
सो दैट यू गेट ऑल द नोटिफिकेशन ऑफ़ द
वीडियोस दैट विल बी कमिंग इन द फ्यूचर।
थैंक यू वेरी मच गाइस। हैव अ गुड नाइट।
टाटा। बाय-ब। टेक केयर एवरीबॉडी। बी
हेल्दी, बी सेफ एंड कीप स्माइलिंग। थैंक
यू वेरी मच।